[Musique]
Guillaume Pitron, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ?
Bien, je m'appelle Guillaume Pitron. Je
suis journaliste. Je suis réalisateur de
documentaires. Je suis chercheur associé
à l'IRIS, l'Institut de relations
internationales et stratégique.
Euh je suis également l'auteur de
plusieurs livres. Un premier pour lequel
vous m'aviez reçu il y a quelques années
de cela, la guerre des métaux rares aux
éditions les liens qui libèrent et plus
récemment auteur d'un autre livre.
L'enfer numérique voyage au bout d'un
like.
Ce soir, on va parler transition
écologique, coût en terme d'énergétique,
coût en terme de consommation de
matière, de métaux,
des répercussions que ça peut avoir sur
nos sociétés, sur l'écologie, la
planète. Quelles sont les
préconisations, les perspectives, les
possibilités
et les liaisons dangereuses que ça peut
avoir sur nos sociétés. On commence par
quoi Guillaume ? On commence par
l'intelligence artificielle ou on
commence par Allez open bar.
Euh bon écoutez, puisque vous me donnez
la parole et que j'ai open bar comme
vous dites. Euh lorsque vous m'avez reçu
la fois dernière, c'était en 2019, on
avait parlé de métau pour la transition
énergétique. On avait évoqué le coût
matériel de réaliser une transition vers
le monde bascarbone. Or, le monde
bascarbone est un monde au métau.
C'est-à-dire qu'il va falloir plus de
métaux et plus de minerais. pour pouvoir
fabriquer les technologies vertes grâce
auxquelles nous allons aller vers un
monde bas carbone. Je m'explique, les
éoliennes, les panneaux solaires, les
voitures électriques, les batteries des
véhicules électriques, tout cela c'est
de la matière, c'est du cuque.
Alors ça c'est la je parle de la partie
transmission énergétique mais c'est du
cuivre, c'est du nickel, c'est du
graphite qui est un minerai important
pour les batteries. Ce sont des terres
rares pour les moteurs de la plupart des
véhicules électriques. C'est
l'aluminium, c'est du fer, c'est du
phosphate pour les batteries
d'aujourd'hui et de demain. Il y a un
coûpt matériel à cela, un coûpt matériau
que l'on avait pas vu venir jusque
maintenant. et à telle enseigne que des
études ont été produites ces dernières
années. Euh notamment une étude de
l'OCDE qui est très intéressante qui
nous dit que nos besoins tout confondus
en matière première en 2060 seront deux
fois deux fois et demi plus élevés que
les besoins de l'humanité en 2011.
Concrètement, ça représente quoi ? Donc
ça veut dire que nous allons consommer
deux fois et demi plus de ressources euh
alimentaires, de x et demi plus de
métaux et de minerais notamment. Et la
transition énergétique qui est une
transition du pétrole vers les matières
premières et minérales et métalliques
est une transition qui accélère en fait
cette consommation de métau et minéraux.
Donc en fait la transition énergétique
est une transition qui d'un côté est une
bonne nouvelle puisque nous allons
émettre moins de CO2 et euh on souhaite
tous la transition énergétique. Et d'un
autre côté B en fait euh je reprends
d'une main ce que j'ai donné de l'autre
parce qu'il va bien falloir aller
chercher ces métaux quelque part avec un
coût absolument colossal. Je vous avais
laissé en 2019 avec un chiffre qui est
toujours d'actualité qui est que pour
tous nos besoins, le BTP, la défense
mais aussi la transition énergétique,
l'humanité va consommer dans les 30
prochaines années plus de métaux et
minéraux que tout ce qu'elle a consommé
depuis 70000 ans. Et dans le même temps,
ces dernières années, on a vu surgir
dans le débat, dans le discours public,
des mots fascinants. dématérialisation
cloud. Je vais mettre mon mon ma ma
fiche de paye dans le cloud
virtualisation avatar que des mots qui
au contraire laissent à penser que parce
que nous déployons les technologies
numériques et l'intelligence
artificielle et bien en fait l'âge est à
la disparition du matériel puisque tout
ça c'est quelque part dans un monde ééré
qu'on appelle le cloud et cela participe
de la dématérialisation et je suis allé
voir mon éditeur au lien qui libère et
je lui dit mais il y a comme un paradoxe
entre la réalité d'un monde toujours
plus matériel. On va être dans un monde
peut-être plus bas carbone, ce que je
souhaite, mais plus haut métaux et aux
minéraux et minéraux et peut-être haute
matière. Et la réalité et et les mots
qui viennent accompagner notre diverses
transitions actuelles qui sont des mots
qui laissent à penser que nous allons
dématérialiser. Et si l'on s'attaquait
ce à ce paradoxe de la
dématérialisation,
y a-t-il réellement une
dématérialisation qui est un discours
très agréable ? On a tous envie
d'entendre parler de dématérialisation
parce que c'est cette promesse que nous
allons pouvoir continuer à croître tout
en ayant un impact moindre sur la
planète et donc que faire rentrer des
rondes dans des carrés, c'est-à-dire
finalement faire de la croissance verte,
de la croissance dématérialisée. Et si
on l'attaquait à ce paradoxe là,
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous avez
découvert en en cherchant, en creusant,
en vous déplaçant
sur ce paradoxe ?
En vous déplaçant sur ce paradoxe, c'est
très beau parce qu'en fait, il faut se
déplacer. C'est-à-dire qu'en fait,
d'abord, je suis parti d'un d'un like,
ça pourrait être une photo de vacances,
un email, un SMS, mais là vous êtes
derrière une caméra Sky à 2,50 de mois à
supposer que je vous adresse un SMS pour
vous dire "J'arrive, tout va bien,
merci". Où va ce like ? Où va ce SMS ?
Où va cette donnée ? Et en fait la
donnée,
ça passe,
où va-t-elle ? Est-ce qu'elle va par
voilà littéralement, c'est en fait elle
va à votre téléphone, ça c'est sûr, mais
par où passe-elle ? Est-ce que
littéralement elle traverse cette pièce
ou est-ce qu'elle passe par un autre
chemin itinéire herbis ? Et en
l'occurrence l'itinérer herbis c'est la
véritable c'est le véritable trajet de
cette donnée puisqueen fait cette donnée
elle va d'abord rejoindre une antenne 4G
qui se trouve peut-être sur le toit de
cet immeuble. Elle va redescendre
ensuite via la fibre optique dans les
parties communes sous le trottoir de la
ville dans laquelle nous nous trouvons à
80 cm de profondeur sous le trottoir
dans de la fibre optique mais aussi des
câbles en cuivre qui vont
progressivement disparaître mais qui
sont encore existants. Elle va rejoindre
cette donnée d'autres données, une
espèce de finalement de de de boîte à
like qui sont les locaotchniques de
l'opérateur. Et puis ce cette donnée,
elle va aller jusqu'à le atlantique, la
côte atlantique française, la vendé
Bordeaux ou peut-être plus au nord vers
Brest. Et elle va traverser le 100
Atlantique parce que cette donnée a été
probablement produite sur un réseau
social américain type par exemple
WhatsApp ou un autre réseau social. et
elle va traverser le centre Atlantique
dans des câbles sous-marins. Elle va
arriver dans des centres de stockage de
données qui se trouvent éparpiés sur le
territoire américain mais notamment sur
la côte est américaine. On pourra y
revenir. Et puis une fois arrivée sur
place, elle va être démultipliée en
plusieurs centres de données parce que
si jamais un centre de données tombe en
panne, on veut pouvoir disposer disposer
quand même de la donnée en temps réel.
Tu as tu as oublé tu as oublié un
passage du Oui.
Tu as oublié un passage. Quand la donnée
arrive aux États-Unis, elle passe dans
les mains et les oreilles de quelques
mouchards. C'est
alors je suis pas trop rentré dedans
mais je pourrais te je pourrais parler
tout à l'heure si vous le voulez de tout
l'impact de la surveillance, le coût
écologique de la surveillance de masse
parce que ça on a des chiffres notamment
via un centre de données de la C de la
NSA qui se trouve dans l'état de l'UTA.
Toujours est-il que cette donnée est
répliquée dans plusieurs centres
données. On redonne les infrastructures
pour les sécuriser, pour sécuriser nos
vies connectées en temps réel et la
donnée va repartir en sens inverse à
travers l'océan Atlantique. Retraverser
la vendée, les côtes de Vendée, arriver
jusqu'à votre téléphone. Donc la
distance entre moi et vous Sky c'est pas
2,50, la distance de 10000 km. Entre
vous et moi, la distance actuelle est de
10000 km. On se' rend pas compte parce
que la donnée, elle est euh elle elle
voyage à la vitesse de la lumière ou
quasi la vitesse de la lumière. 200 m000
km/s. Euh c'est la vitesse de la
transmission de l'information dans les
câbles optiques. Mais pour autant donc
la donnée, elle va arriver dans la
seconde à votre téléphone parce que la
donnée voyage très rapidement et pour
autant on ignore la réalité matérielle
du voyage de cette donnée, ce fameux
voyage d'un like et on ignore toute
l'infrastructure qui se trame derrière
tout ça pour vivre des vies sensément
dématérialisées. Et si on enquêtait
pendant quelques années le long de cette
route, si on suivait littéralement point
par point le voyage du like, vous savez,
moi j'adore les matières premières. Je
fais ce métier de journaliste depuis 15
ans 17 ans et j'adore suivre les
matières premières. euh la matière le
pétrole, la route d'une tomate, d'une
terre rare, mais j'adore aussi suivre la
route des migrants. Donc ce sont des
c'est c'est concrètement des hommes, des
femmes, c'est très physique, c'est très
concret que l'on suit à travers
l'Afrique jusqu'au jusqu'aux rivages
européens où quelquefois d'ailleurs
beaucoup de migrants restent en Afrique.
Je pas je termine ce par ce ce cette
explication là pour vous dire qu'on peut
aussi suivre la route d'une donnée, de
quelque chose qui paraît aussi
immatériel. d'aussi impalpable, d'aussi
irréel, d'aussi intangible qu'un like.
Et en fait, c'est très tangible, c'est
très matériel, c'est très concret. Et
donc en remontant la route de cette
donnée, de toutes ces données et bien en
fait on touche à l'infrastructure
internet. L'infrastructure internet
Greenpeace est en passe de devenir l'une
des choses les plus immenses, les plus
vastes que l'homme n'a jamais construite
pour vivre nos vies connectées. C'est
une infrastructure qui est souterraine,
qui est sous-marine, qui est
extraatmosphérique.
On l'appelle pas forcément
suprastructure, elle est infra, elle est
sous nous, on ne la voit pas et pourtant
c'est grâce à cela que nos vies sont
connectées et il y a un coût matériel à
cette immatériel. et notre monde
matériel dématérialisé pardon est un
monde finalement qui est très matériel.
Et donc c'est tout ce paradoxe que j'ai
essayé de toucher.
On essaiera euh durant cet entretien de
parler aussi des risques géopolitiques
de cette infrastructure en terme de
géopolitique des câbles, en terme de
d'uasion nucléaire nord-coréenne
qui veut faire péter tous les satellites
avec euh une ionisation euh par armes
nucléaire et et d'autres petits détails
que nos politiques ont l'air de
sous-estimer à concrètement. On voit que
ils ont pas l'air très au fait de la
situation.
Quel
quand vous avez découvert le coût
énergétique, le coût matériel de de ces
data,
quelle quelle en a été votre déduction
et quels sont les chemins que ça va nous
obliger à prendre en terme
d'exploitation, d'ouverture de mine,
d'ouverture d'infrastructure ? Et
éthiquement parlant aussi, on reviendra
sur l'éthique de de la data et de
l'intelligence artificielle. Qu'est-ce
que vous en avez fait émerger ? C'est
viable, c'est pas viable ? Est-ce que
c'est une vraie transition écologique ?
Est-ce que la dématérialisation de la
data nous télétransporte dans un monde
vert avec des bullshit word à tous les
coins de rue où réellement est-ce que ça
ça va fonctionner ?
Alors, d'abord, il faut savoir que le
numérique peut-être et l'IA et
l'intelligence artificielle au sens
large peuvent être mis peuvent être mis
pardon au service de l'environnement.
C'est c'est une réalité. C'est-à-dire
que on passe aujourd'hui notre vie à
avoir des réunions sur Zoom, Teams ou
Google Meet avec des gens qui se
trouvent à le bout du monde queon aurait
pu concrètement aller voir en se
déplaçant et en prenant un avion avec un
coup carbone que l'on sait. Et pour
autant, le lien physique et la connexion
humaine entre ces personnes, moi la
première, se fait par la grâce de ces
infrastructures numériques qui ne
m'obligent plus à me déplacer. Donc il y
a un gain qui est réel, mais je peux
mentionner des tas d'autres gains tout à
fait réels. Euh songer par exemple à moi
j'aime bien citer cette application, je
le fais un peu pub ce soir, c'est Too
Togo. Euh Togu to Go, c'est une
application qui est très connue en fait
qui met en relation des vendeurs et des
consommateurs de des consommateurs de
produits périssables. Vous avez une
tomate qui est concrètement pourrie dans
24 heures et puis vous avez un acheteur.
Comment s'appelle la fondatrice de ça ?
Alors vous avez raison, c'est une
fondatrice, elle est française et je
n'ai pas son nom à l'instant et vous
l'avez. se rencontre au moment d'un je
vois qu'il y a déjà des réponses en
direct mais l'offre et la demande vont
vont se vont se rencontrer.
Et donc en fait ce qui est très
intéressant c'est que là tout d'un coup
c'est un gain écologique évident puisque
à partir du moment où vous gâ vous
gaspillez moins, du coup ça veut dire
que vous avez moins besoin de produire
de nouvelles tomates. Mais qui dit moins
de production
alimentaire agricole veut dire quoi ?
Bah moins de déforestation, moins
d'intrant, moins de pesticides, moins de
transport. Donc c'est typiquement un
exemple très intéressant du gain que le
numérique peut générer sur
l'environnement. Et un un véritable
discours s'est construit ces derres
années porté par des études dont on peut
d'ailleurs discuter la la viabilité, le
sérieux mais tendant à montrer que
certes le coût numérique sur
l'environnement réel mais que les gains
euh sont largement contrebalancés
contrebalancent largement dépassent
largement les les coûts écologiques.
Donc ça c'est la bonne nouvelle et il
faut insister là-dessus. La transition
énergétique sans numérique, elle ne peut
pas être faite. Le euh la transition
énergétique, ce sont les énergies
intermittentes. Ça veut dire que vous
avez du soleil qui ne rayonne pas tout
le temps et du vent qui ne souffle pas
tout le temps. Comment est-ce qu'on gère
l'intermittence ? Seul le pilotage
informatique des réseaux euh enfin des
réseaux énergétiques peut permettre et
bien en fait de faire se rencontrer en
temps réel l'offre et la demande. Donc
le numérique est absolument
indispensable. Euh la transition
énergétique est une transition qui doit
s'appuyer sur le numérique. Donc c'est
un gain
et sur le nucléaire
et sur le ncléaire qui a l'avantage de
pas être une énergie intermittente
puisque'en fait vous pouvez décider de
quand vous éteignez la centrale ou quand
vous l'allumez et elle a l'avantage mais
de même que l'hydraulique par exemple
l'hydroélectricité pardon d'être une
énergie qui peut être davantage dont la
production peut-être davantage organisée
pour limiter l'intermittence mais si
nous allons vers un monde plus vert et
bien nous allons vers plus enfin au sens
des technologies éoliennes solaires.
Nous allons vers un monde avec plus de
technologies d'énergie intermittente et
le numérique doit être au service de
cette de ces de ces sources
d'électricité là. Pour autant,
un peu de schizophrénie entre tout ça.
Alors, c'est là qu'il y a une
schizophrénie que je que l'on touche du
doigt, c'est qu'en fait d'abord tout ça
c'est un coût et c'est un coup qui est
matériel et la première des le premier
des coûts du numérique c'est un coût
matériel. Et il y a un coût qui est par
ailleurs est est énergétique parce qu'en
fait il faut de l'électricité pour faire
tourner les centres de stockage de
données. Il faut de l'électricité pour
les la mine
refroidir les stockages de données.
Alors les refroidir grâce à les systèmes
de climatisation qui sont énergivor et
qui représentent ça dépend des centres
de données mais entre 30 et 40 50 % de
la consommation du centre de données. Et
tout ça, c'est un coût d'abord
électrique. Et on considère que le
numérique au sens large du terme de la
mine jusqu'au centre de stockage de
données en passant par le recyclage du
métal de votre téléphone, c'est environ
10 % de la consommation de l'électricité
mondiale. Et c'est un coût qui serait
susceptible d'augmenter avec la
numérisation de nos sociétés. C'est un
coûpt matériel, c'est-à-dire qu'il faut
de la matière pour produire le monde
sensément immatériel qu'on appelle
peut-être le métaverse si on décide d'y
aller ou en tout cas le numérique
internet. Très concrètement, vous avez
dans votre téléphone, dans votre la
poche, enfin dans votre poche un
téléphone et dans ce téléphone, vous
avez des matières premières et vous en
avez beaucoup. vous avez 50 60 70
matières premières dans un téléphone.
Chacune de ces matières euh c'est un un
approvisionnement et souvent un
approvisionnement issu d'une mine. Par
exemple, vous avez euh dans votre
téléphone une batterie qui est faite de
lithium, de cobalt, euh de nickel, de
cuivre, de graphite. Vous avez un aimant
permanent qui est lui-même fait de
néodîme. C'est une terre rare. Et cet é
permanent, il vibre quand vous êtes en
mode vibreur. Quand vous téléphone
vibre, pensez-y. Mais c'est grâce à un
aimant de terre rare. Vous avez un écran
qui est aujourd'hui tactile. Mais
comment est-ce qu'il est tactile ? Bah,
il est tactile parce qu'en fait on l'a
recouvert d'un oxyde, une poudre qui en
fait rend confère à vos écrans leur
qualité tactile. Est-ce que
Très facile à recycler d'ailleurs.
Non, très difficile à recycler
sans déconner
parce qu'en fait le l'oxyde est
littéralement fondu dans l'écran. Donc
on va pas recycler ça. Mais Sky, est-ce
que vous rappelez l'âge d'avant l'indium
d'un
Est-ce que vous rappelez l'âge d'avant
cet oxyde qu'on appelle l'indium qui
rend vos écrans tactiles ?
Oui, je me rappelle très bien.
C'était l'âge des téléphones à 12
touches et il me fallait 3 minutes pour
écrire "J'arrive avec un correcteur de
texte et personne n'a envie de revenir à
l'âge d'abon l'indium". Tout le monde
est très heureux d'avoir de l'indiom
dans sa poche qui rend nos vies
tellement plus fluides.
Est-ce que tu en est-ce que vous en êtes
tellement sûr de ça ? Est-ce qu'une
machine a remonté le temps nous ramenant
à l'époque des tamtam, des bibop et des
dictionnaires T9 ?
Et c'était pas une meilleure époque.
Ah, écoutez, moi je j'ai pensé ces
dernières semaines revenir à à un Noka.
J'ai vraiment pensé
un 3310
Ouais, un 33 ou un 6310. Mais vraiment,
j'ai j'ai pensé vraiment l'acheter. En
fait, il y en a chez Dy, j'ai vu, ils
ont été complètement redesignés, ils
sont tout beaux et je me suis dit, je
vais me passer en fait de de mon
téléphone sur lequel je vais tout le
temps et je vais essayer de m' de me
déshabituer de de cette technologie là,
désintoxiqué complètement. Et en fait,
j'ai pas réussi à faire le chemin parce
que je me suis rendu compte que j'en ai
besoin pour même pas forcément pour
aller sur TikTok. Je suis pas sur TikTok
mais j'ai besoin de de de la base du
téléphone 10 smartphone à savoir partage
de connection
internet quelques applications
d'information je ne peux pas m'en passer
donc je ne reviendrai pas je pense à ces
téléphones du monde d'avant mais et donc
je ne reviendrai pas au monde d'avant
l'indium je n'y reviendrai pas je pense.
Donc je pense que néanmoins c'est un
progrès et vous me voyez plutôt adapter
ou épouser certains progrès numériques
évidemment, mais tout ça pour vous dire
qu'il y a de la matière et cette matière
il faut bien chercher quelque part. Donc
euh derrière toutes les matières de
votre téléphone, il y a des mines. Et
ces mines-là, faut pas oublier que tout
ce qui est matériel et nuage naît d'une
entaille dans le sol une mine. Et moi,
j'ai passé des années, des années et j'y
continue d'ailleurs, je continue d'aller
dans les mines, de me rendre dans ces
zones grises dont on n'est jamais
frière, même les mines les plus
respectueuses et standards
internationaux, c'est toujours une
entaille dans le sol et ça reste ça
reste un impact qui va durer dans le
temps et quelquefois va être un impact
qui va rester à vitamern parce qu'on va
pas faire de la post mining,
c'est-à-dire qu'on va pas réparer ces
impacts après la fin de la mise en
production de la mine et il Il faut bien
avoir conscience de ça pour insister
dans ce sens-là parce que c'est vraiment
votre question matérielle. Les
Allemands, des chercheurs allemands d'un
institut de recherche qui s'appelle le
Vupertal Institute dans la ville éponyme
ont mis au point il y a quelques années
de cela un ratio qui qu'on appelle le
sac à dos écologique ou appelé en terme
plus complexe le MIPS, le matériel input
per service unit. En fait, ça consiste à
faire le ratio entre le poids final d'un
produit et toute la matière qui a été
nécessaire pour le produire. En gros, il
faut plus de ressources que ma chemise
pour produire le poids final de ma
chemise. Ma chemise est faite en coton
mais pour du coton, il faut euh
de l'irrigation.
De l'irrigation, il y a peut-être fallu
déforester, il a fallu le transporter.
Donc il faut un peu de pétrole dans je
ne sais quel tracteur. Donc en fait on
va et puis après une fois que bah en
fait ma balle de coton, il va falloir la
transformer et puis on la transformer en
tissu et puis ce tissu, il va être
assemblé et puis ensuite le la chemise
va être transportée jusque dans le
magasin où je l'ai acheté. Tout ça c'est
un ensemble de coûts matériel et donc en
fait le MIPS c'est le ratio entre le
poids final de ma chemise quelques
centaines de grammes et toute la
ressource qui du depuis le champ de
coton jusqu'au magasin, je parle pas
encore après du recyclage va être
nécessaire pour pouvoir fabriquer cette
chemise et on arrive à un ratio qui est
de 30 40 pour un 50 pour un 100 pour un
c'est assez classique. Il faut des
dizaines de fois plus de matière que le
poids final de mon produit parce que il
y a un coût en eau de ma chemise. Si je
pousse cela à des produits connectés qui
sont des produits excessivement
complexes, qui sont des produits qui
contiennent comme on l'a vu des dizaines
de matériaux qui sont des produits
souvent très dilués dans les corces
terrestres. C'estàd que le néodimme, une
terre rare qui fait vibrer votre
téléphone, c'est un matériau pour lequel
il faut un vrai effort extractif, un
vrai effort énergétique pour pouvoir le
raffiner et le mettre dans votre
téléphone. Bien, si on multiplie tout ça
par les dizaines de matériaux qui se
trouvent dans votre téléphone, on
aboutit à un MIPS, un sac à dos
écologique qui n'est pas de 40 pour un
ou de 50 pour un ou de 100 pour un mais
pour un téléphone, il est de 1200 pour
un. Donc il faut 1200 fois plus de
matière que le poids final de votre
téléphone. C'est que votre téléphone il
pèse pas 150 g, il pèse 182 ou 183 kg.
Et c'est encore plus vrai pour une puce
électronique qui est le cerveau de votre
téléphone. La puce électronique c'est
l'ambième de la mondialisation. C'est un
objet d'une complexité folle. Il y a 50
matières premières dans une puce
électronique. C'est absolument
incroyable. Et bien cette puce
électronique, elle peut avoir un ratio
qui va jusqu'à 16000 pour un. Il faut
16000 fois plus de ressources. que le
poids final de la puce. Donc si votre
puce pèse 2 g, il faut jusqu'à 32 kg de
ressources. Ça nous dit quoi tout ça ?
Bah ça nous dit en fait que plus c'est
léger dans la poche, plus c'est lourd.
Plus c'est petit dans la poche, merci la
miniaturisation, plus paradoxalement
l'impact lui est gros. Et ça nous dit
que plus peut-être c'est virtuel ou cela
ne nous dit-il pas, je vais le poser
sous forme de question que plus c'est
virtuel, est-ce que ce n'est pas
paradoxalement davantage matériel ?
puisque plus nous allons vers des objets
qui sont la porte d'entrée dans le monde
virtuel, ces objets sont des interfaces,
les téléphones, les tablettes, les
ordinateurs. Plus il y a une
complexification, plus il y a de
ressources et plus il y a un coût
matière qui est élevé. Donc je pose la
question, est-ce que plus c'est virtuel,
plus n'est-ce pas paradoxalement
matériel ? Et
est-ce que c'est plus c'est vert ? C'est
moins moins ça produit de carbone plus
en fait c'est
sale.
Bah en fait plus c'est vert donc plus
c'est zéro émission plus paradoxalement
il faut de métau. Aujourd'hui on
considère que une voiture électrique
c'est évidemment moins d'émission de CO2
surtout en France que lorsqu'on est en
voiture thermique. On roule en voiture
thermique. C'est moins vrai quand vous
êtes en Chine parce que en Chine une
voiture électrique elle est rechargée
d'électricité qui a été produite à base
de charbon et de pétrole. C'est
malheureusement le mix électrique
chinois. Pour autant, ça reste un gain
en terme d'émission de CO2 par rapport à
la voiture thermique, mais c'est pas
idéal. Mais en tout cas, disons
globalement que la voiture électrique,
c'est mieux que la voiture thermique en
terme d'émission de CO2. Mais une
voiture électrique et c'est un chiffre
de l'Agence internationale de l'énergie
nécessite pendant l'ensemble de son
cycle de vie et pour sa fabrication
évidemment surtout six fois plus de
ressources que la voiture thermique.
Donc vous avez un coût matière et
matériaux et métau qui est plus élevé
pour une voiture électrique que pour une
voiture thermique. Donc vous gagnez d'un
côté, vous êtes moins sale parce que
moins d'émission de CO2 mais vous perdez
de l'autre parce que vous avez besoin de
plus de métaux par rapport au à
l'homologue thermique. Il y a il y a il
y a pas des puces à base de cellulose ou
d'autres technologies qui permettraient
de de baisser notre impact, notre
pression sur le biotope ? Alors, des
puces, je ne sais pas, mais des
batteries, oui. Et donc tout l'enjeu
aujourd'hui, c'est une course de vitesse
puisqu'en fait la technologie dit et
notamment les chimistes dit "Mais en
fait, on est au devant et nous
accompagnons une révolution de la chimie
parce que les voitures électriques sont
faites aujourd'hui avec des batteries
euh nickel, manganes, cobalt avec un
coût euh matière important et un coût
énergétique et un coût écologique. Mais
paradoxalement, on va enfin c'est
paradoxalement, c'est que on développe
de nouvelles technologies de stockage et
notamment la grande technologie qui est
aujourd'hui fait rêver les Chinois et va
peut-être faire rêver les Européens,
c'est la technologie LFP, lithium fer,
phosphate et d'autres technologies dont
on peut reparler. Le LFP, c'est l'idée
qu'on va en fait se passer du nickel et
du cobalt et qu'en fait on va substituer
certains matériaux qui sont plus rares
que d'autres, plus dilués dans les corps
terrestres, plus compliqué à extraire
avec un coût écologique plus élevé par
d'autres matériaux plus abondants,
typiquement le fer qui est plutôt très
abondant et qui et bien va permettre un
coût écologique de la voiture électrique
et de la batterie qui va être moindre.
Donc il y a une course de vitesse mais
moindre dans quelle proportion c'est
quantifiable ? Est-ce que c'est moindre
pour dire cosmétique ou c'est réellement
moindre ? Et ça va permettre d'avoir de
diminuer
notre impact ? C'est très compliqué
comme question parce que en fait oui
c'est quantifiable mais comprenez bien
que et là je suis obligé de citer
Stephen Hawking, l'avenir est une course
entre la puissance croissante de nos
technologies et la sagesse avec laquelle
on va être capable de les utiliser. En
gros, je peux toujours faire des
batteries plus efficientes et l'avenir
est à des batteries toujours plus
efficientes et c'est une très bonne
nouvelle. Pour autant, immédiatement
s'installe euh émerge ce qu'on appelle
un effet rebond. C'estàd que puisque je
pollue moins par kilomètre émis,
c'est peut-être moins cher
puisque c'est moins cher puisque comme
j'ai regardé une publicité à 19h55 sur
une grande chaîne qui m'a gavé de ma
voiture propre, zéro émission,
responsable, durable, tout ce que vous
voulez, bah du coup je vais pouvoir
rouler encore un peu plus parce que de
toute façon j'ai l'illusion, je parle
pas d'une illusion hein de ne pas
polluer. Alors évidemment vous polluez
mais simplement vous polluez pas quand
vous roulez, vous polluez. OK. Quelqu'un
doit polluer chez lui pour que vous
puissiez être responsable envers la
génération future et être propre, être
vert, être zéro émission chez vous. Mais
puisque j'ai cette illusision là, et
bien en fait je vais surconsommer. Et
donc l'effet rebond, c'est le l'effet
boomerang de l'amélioration
technologique. Je m'améliore
technologiquement mais du coup mes
voitures électriques, elles sont plus
lourdes. Je vais davantage les utiliser.
Et donc en fait on arrive à un effet
rebond où concrètement je boucle sur
cette idée où je ne suis pas
complètement certain et ça vaut pour le
technologique, le numérique et c'est là
que c'est schizophrène. Je ne suis pas
certain que l'amélioration technologique
et la la rapidité de de l'amélioration
technologique en terme de gain matière
d'efficience CO2 soit aussi rapide que
l'explosion des nouveaux modes de
consommation que cela génère. Et c'est
là pour répondre à votre question que
tout cela est complètement schizophrène.
Et c'est là que le numérique est
schizophrène. C'est qu'en fait le
numérique promet une dématérialisation
là où en fait il rematérialise pour
partie. Et c'est là que le numérique
génère un surplu de consommation CF chat
GPT puisque jusque maintenant j'allais
sur Google pour faire une recherche et
maintenant je pose la question à chat
GPT avec un coût qui est en terme
environnemental qui est plus élevé sur
chat GPT pour une recherche.
Ça a été quantifié par qui ? C'est quoi
votre source ? Alors, ça a été
quantifié.
J'ai juste immédiatement le trou du
rapport que j'ai regardé en plus 5
minutes avant d'arriver sur ce plateau
qui en fait qualif quantifie l'impact
l'impact environnemental de chat GPT.
Mais on on le réévoquera mais le chat
GPT c'est phase d'entraînement, phase
d'inférence, c'està-dire d'utilisation.
On parle du 3, tout ça a été calculé. On
sait que c'est en gros
des centaines ou des milliers de tonnes,
mais je peux vous citer les chiffres
très précisement si vous voulez euh
d'émission de de CO2 pour la phase
d'inférence, la phase de de de
d'entraînement et la phase
d'utilisation. Et chat GPT4 est encore
plus élevé que cela en fait. Donc en
gros, c'est moins bien d'aller sur chatt
soucieux de l'environnement que d'être
sur une recherche sur Google. Donc en
fait, c'est un c'est un effet rebond
permanent qui fait que je suis pas sûr
que les gains soient ne soient pas
contrebalancés par les pertes du à mes
consommation
aggravé de ces matériaux, de ces outils.
Alors le le fait d'aller sur chat GPT
c'est les gens font ce qu'ils veulent
mais il y a il y a quand même cette
pression sur le le biotop. Ce type de
boîte, ce type d'entreprise travaille
pour diminuer leur consommation
énergétique. Vous avez suivi ça ?
Le rapport c'est Data for Good. Data for
Good, c'est un rapport qui a été publié,
je ne sais plus exactement la date. Les
chiffres pour être vraiment auprès de de
ceux qui nous écoutent et nous regardent
euh sont très précisément évoqués. 552
tonnes de d'émission de CO2 équivalent
pour la phase
d'entraînement
et 220 fois plus pour la phase de
d'utilisation de chat GPT3. et les coûts
de chat GPT4 qu'on ne connaît pas parce
que Open AI ne communique pas sur ses
coûts mais serait au moins 10 fois
supérieur sinon 100 fois supérieur face
à cela, qu'est-ce que font les
entreprises ? Évidemment qu'elles ont
conscience de ces sujets-là et pour ell
ça devient un vrai sujet parce que
d'abord c'est un coût énergétique pour
commencer donc on va éviter de dépenser
plus d'énergie et donc de payer plus à
la fin du mois. Donc si j'ai un
numérique plus sobre bah du coup et
moins énergivor du coup je vais faire
des économies. Euh c'est un coût
réputationnel parce que le on commence à
comprendre ces impacts-là, le public
commence à percevoir la réalité de ces
impacts écologiques-là. Comment et
notamment en France ? On est assez en
avance en France. Je dis pas ça parce
que nous sommes français mais
Cocoricou
non parce que les Français, les
Allemands et les scandinaves ont une
perception beaucoup plus fine et et
claire des impacts environnementaux du
numérique. Je reviens des États-Unis,
ils sont largués quoi. Déjà qu'aux
États-Unis, on n'est pas sûr que le
climat se réchauffe parce que
malheureusement c'est
pour leur tête pour une partie des
Américains.
Malheureusement pour une partie d'entre
eux, c'est tristement la réalité. Mais
alors quant à leur dire qu'un email ça
pollue, c'est euh c'est c'est
vertigineux comme démonstration. Donc en
France, on est quand même plus avancé
sur ces sujets-là. Donc les entreprises
sont conscientes de ces enjeux-là et
elles sont conscientes que ça va demain
être un un enjeu réputationnel pour
elles, notamment pour les grandes
entreprises de centres de stockage de
données et puis c'est un enjeu aussi de
ressources humaines. C'est que vous
voulez embaucher des jeunes de la
génération Greta qui ont une conscience
écologique plus affinée que celle de la
génération précédente, mais je sens que
vous allez me relancer là-dessus. Euh et
bien euh vous avez envie d'avoir une
communication, des actions qui soient
cohérentes avec les valeurs de cette
génération là et donc il faut pouvoir
avoir une politique donc de réduction
des impacts. Donc là ce que vous êtes
dans les entreprises de la tech, vous
allez avoir tout un discours qui
clairement est aussi et largement
emprint de green washing total mais
aussi he pas que mais qui consiste
effectivement à dire qu'on va baisser
les impacts du numérique. Et ça passe
par toutes sortes de réorganisation de
l'architecture de votre centre de
stockage de données et ça passe Sky par
le fait de déplacer le cloud dans le
Grand Nord. C'est-à-dire qu'en fait
c'est quoi ? On l'a dit tout à l'heure
le cloud, c'est de la consommation
d'électricité. Donc ça veut dire que
vous allez devoir le refroidir pour
refroidir les serveurs à 20 25°gr
et on le refroidit avec des systèmes de
clismatisation énergivore. Mais si je
déplace mes vidéos de chat, mes emails,
mes likes, mes photos de vacances dans
le grand nord européen, mer
non mais si je le déplace en Laponie, là
où il fait naturellement froid, là où il
y a du froid gratuit, du free cooling et
si je simplifie mais j'ouvre la porte de
mon centre de stockage de données et je
laisse le bliard à - 40° rentrer et
rafraîchir naturellement mes vidéos de
chat, ben en fait j'ai je débranche la
clime, elle est naturelle, je fais du
froid gratuit, je profite du froid
gratuit et donc du coup
l'extérieur
Alors, peut-être que je chauffe
l'extérieur, mais en tout cas, je
refroidis sans euh consommation
d'électricité euh mes données, mon
cloud, le nuage
et donc du coup et donc du coup et bien
en fait je gagne ici un il y a un gain
écologique qui peut être réel. Il y a il
y a un gain aussi monétaire, non ? Et
il y a un gain monétaire évidemment
puisque'en fait vous avez moins besoin
de de percuter vos coups. OK. Question
internet. Est-ce que Guillaume s'est
intéressé aux questions de calcul haute
performance pour les data center ? à
température cryogénique.
Ouais. Alors ça je je pas rentrer
là-dedans et puis je sais pas comment
est-ce qu'on stockerait des données à
une telle température. Mais en tout cas
ce qui est sûr c'est que euh on fait des
calculs de performance. Il y a un ratio
qu'on connaît dans l'industrie des
centres données qui s'appelle le PE PUE,
le power unit efficiency qui consiste à
calculer en fait la performance
énergétique du stockage d'une quantité X
de données. Et en fait les centres de
stockage de données courent après ce
type de PUE là qui était très élevé il y
a quelques années qui baisse
progressivement. on atteint 1,3 1,2 et
qui montre en fait l'effort qu'elles
font, les efforts qu'elles font pour
finalement et bien comment dirais-je
maximiser l'utilisation de l'électricité
proportionnellement à la quantité de
données euh consommées. Mais encore une
fois, on va consommer toujours plus de
données.
Juste une, on va revenir là-dessus.
Juste une autre question. Tu vous êtes
intéressé au data center dans les pays
producteurs de gaz ? Pas du tout. Alors
les pays pour les tours de gaz, moi je
pense à au Qatar ou
à l'Algérie.
Alors les data centers, je me suis pas
spécialement intéressé au centre de
stockage de données en Algérie. J'ai
regardé ça côté marocain pour tout vous
dire. Après, je me suis intéressé au
data center dans les pays où
l'électricité provient du charbon.
Alors, en fait, vous avez un grand hub
de stockage de données qui se trouve aux
États-Unis, au sud de Washington DC,
donc sur la côte est- américaine dans
une ville qui s'appelle Hburn. Et pour
de raisons historiques qu'on peut
expliquer, mais Hburn s'est mué ces
dernières années, même ces dernières, en
silicone valet des centres de stockage
de données parce que l'électricité est
pas cher, parce qu'elle est abondante,
parce que le foncier est lui-même
accessible. Ashburn est devenu ce qu'on
appelle une cité nuage, une cloud city.
C'est-à-dire qu'en fait c'est un
rassemblement physique de tas
d'industriels parce que je les considère
comme des industriels du stockage de
données. Amazon Web Services, Microsoft
Azure pour ne citer que et qui en fait
se rassemble dans cette ville-là. Or,
une partie de l'électricité euh qui est
fournie par euh euh qui est fourni par
les par les fournisseurs d'électricité
locaux euh à ces industriels est une
électricité qui provient du charbon des
appalaches. Les appalaches, c'est une
chaîne de montagne qui euh en fait
descend enfin file vers le sud des
États-Unis depuis le sud du Canada à 700
km dans les terres. Et donc il faut se
rendre dans les mines de charbon où on
fait péter à la dynamite les sommets de
montagne pour récupérer le charbon qui
lui-même sert ensuite pour partie dans
le mix dans le bouquet électrique euh de
la production d'électricité américaine
et qu'elle-même termine pour les
systèmes de refroidissement des centres
de stockage de données de cette ville
qui est l'une des plus grandes villes de
stockage de données de la planète. Et
donc là, on prend conscience du lien
entre l'immatériel qui est ma vidéo de
chat stockée sur un serveur et la
réalité que tout ça ça réchauffe la
planète puisque le charbon a été
préalablement brûlé pour produire
l'électricité du stockage de
question internet il est maintenant
possible de faire tourner des I sur des
équipements personnels à des coûts
abordables. Un GPU avec 12 Go de NV RAM
300 € donne de bons résultats. Va-t-on
avoir une explosion d'acquisition de
matériel HW personnel ? plutôt que
centraliser dans des data center à la
chat GPT.
Alors, c'est une question de DSI là de
directeur des services informatiques ou
d'informaticien. Je vous précise, j'ai
fait un bac L. Euh donc là, je vais pas
être capable de répondre à votre
question.
Non, mais j'ai fait je suis journaliste
et je suis extrêmement je fouille les
faits mais là je je suis pas rentré dans
ce détail précis. Ce que je peux
répondre à votre question, c'est que
nous sommes avec une technologie, nous
sommes en possession d'une technologie
qui se démocratise euh aujourd'hui.
Combien vont-nous d'écrans ? Et
comparaison ce nombre d'écrans au nombre
d'écrans dont nous disposions il y a
encore quelques années de cela. Et nous
allons toujours davantage vers ce type
de de d'évolution là. Mon Google Drive a
une puissance, une capacité de stockage
qui n'a rien à voir avec le capacité de
stockage qui m'était offerte par Google
Drive il y a encore 5 ou 10 ans. Donc je
répondrai pas spécifiquement à votre
question qui est extrêmement pointu,
j'ai pas la réponse, je ne sais pas.
Mais pour vous dire que il est logique
que nous allions vers des systèmes
davantage d'acquisition de ces
technologies là à notre titre personnel
et peut-être des systèmes qui soient
peut-être aussi plus décentralisés.
Alors là, c'est une question très
importante et d'ailleurs qui va nous
faire rebondir sur tout un tas de sujets
de cette interview. Question pour
l'invité. Bonsoir, j'ai été créateur de
contenu pour une entreprise
internationale spécialisée dans
l'intelligence informatique. Je
artificiel pardon. Je me suis rendu
compte que les clients de la boîte en
question n'étaient pas du genre
vertueux. Entre parenthèses, une liste
de de boîtes long comme le bras
euh des jusqu'où des agences de
surveillance des frontières. J'ai
l'impression d'avoir nourri un monstre
au-delà du coût énergéti écologique
d'une société technologique à l'extrême
extrême. Pensez-vous que l'IA sert
majoritairement les intérêts
d'entreprise ou d'États très éloignés du
bien commun. Je la repose. Non,
j'ai compris, j'ai compris.
J'ai l'impression d'avoir nourri un
monstre. Au-delà du coût écologique
d'une société technologisée à l'extrême,
pensez-vous que l'intelligence
artificielle sert majoritairement des
intérêts d'entreprise ou des États très
orientés, très éloignés du bien commun ?
Vous me posez une question qui est
absolument immense. Il faudrait 3 heures
pour y répondre. Euh
LIA est ni bonne, ni mauvaise, ni
neutre.
Elle est ambigue. C'est
elle elle est ce qu'on en fait.
Elle est ce qu'on en fait. Est-ce qu'on
en fait ? Est-ce que ce qu'on a ce que
l'on en a fait, qui l'a fait ? Comment
on l'a fait ? Quels sont les biais ? Et
évidemment les fonctions des biais et
vous savez mieux que moi tous les biais
qui peuvent être racistes, sexistes,
desia
ou inversement ou inversement.
Absolument.
Qui peuvent être ultra w ultra
friendly avec
Totalement. Totalement. Totalement. Donc
pour le bien commun, je moi ce que je
peux vous répondre c'est que parce que
je je reviens à à ce que je maîtrise
mieux et on parlait de l'environnement
mais l'IA n'a pas été le numérique n'ont
pas été déployé au service de
l'environnement. C'est pas le sujet. Il
y a le numérique ont été déployés, ils
sont déployés au service de la
croissance, au service de la puissance
mais pas au service
au service du pognon. On n'est pas là
pour sauver la planète. Il se passe que
tout d'un coup ce coût explose. C'est
une consommation d'électricité. Ce sont
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre.
Tout à l'heure, enfin je vous l'ai pas
dit mais le numérique en général, on
considère que c'est environ 4 % des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre. Donc
c'est plus que le l'avion et c'est c'est
ce chiffre là pour augmenter. Ça dépend
des scénarios. L'ADEM fait des scénarios
mais sur un dans des scénarios dans les
tendances et les dynamiques business as
usual où on change rien ce coup-là va
exploser. Et tout d'un coup surgit ce
débat qui est un véritable sujet qui est
perçu comme étant un enjeu de réputation
par l'industrie des centres de stockage
de données, l'industrie numérique au
sens large du terme qui veut en fait
faire coïncider numérique croissance
enrichissement et environnement. People
Planè profite, une coordature du cercle
et je ne crois pas un instant à ce
vernivers. Je pense pas un instant que
le numérique soit fait pour cela.
Aujourd'hui, si vous n'êtes pas dans le
numérique, si vous n'êtes pas dans le
cyberespace, et ben c'est la Russie qui
est dans le cyberespace ou c'est la
Chine ou ce sont les États-Unis. Si vous
n'avez pas votre propre flotte de
satellite qui propose des services
d'internet spatial, et bien ce sont
d'autres pays peut-être moins
attentionnés et moins bienveillants à
votre endroit qui vont le faire. Si euh
jamais je n'ai pas mes propres antennes
5G, c'est les Chinois Huawei qui vont
déployer des anes des antennes 5G et on
ne sait pas vraiment ce qu'ils ont mis
dans leurs antennes 5G. Donc en fait,
nous sommes en Europe, pour prendre
l'exemple européen, pris dans une espèce
de contradiction totale, une forme de
schizophrénie entre la prise de
conscience de l'impact croissant de
numérique sur l'environnement et que si
jamais on veut le faire coïncider avec
les accords de Paris, il va falloir
changer sa façon de faire, enfin changer
la façon de le consommer et pour autant
une technologisation accrue de nos
sociétés et une numérisation accrue de
nos sociétés parce que de toute façon si
on ne le fait pas et bien en fait il des
questions de souveraineté technologique,
de souveraineté géopolitique et de ne
pas faire sortir l'Europe de de
l'histoire vraiment. Et je ne voudrais
pas aujourd'hui être un de nos
dirigeants qui probablement plus ou
moins conscience de ces sujets-là, mais
sont face à un vrai une vraie
schizophrénie, notre schizophrénie qui
est de vouloir mettre le service le
numérique au service de l'environnement
alors que je le crois profondément, il
ne peut pas être compatible avec les
accords de Paris mais tout en ne pouvant
pas se passer de cette technologie là
qui aujourd'hui est concrètement la
condition d'une forme de souveraineté
dont nous avons besoin dans un monde qui
géopolitiquement se tend. Donc qu'est-ce
qu'on fait ? Et ben on passe de lois des
lois pour optimiser. Donc c'est la loi
RINE 2021, loi française sur la
réduction de l'empreinte
environnementale du numérique. On
optimise, on essaie de faire plus avec
moins, on demande au susé data center de
faire plus avec moins. C'est les fameux
PE que j'ai évoqué. Et donc en fait, on
ne cesse d'essayer d'optimiser pour
pouvoir tenter de faire rentrer des des
ronds dans des carrés. Mais nous sommes
face à une véritable schizophrénie, je
crois. Et le numérique soulève enfin met
avant, met en lumière les paradoxes de
cette dématérialisation qui n'en fait
qu'une surmatérialisation
dont on ne peut pas se passer si l'on
perçoit tous les enjeux géopolitiques
technologiques qui se trament derrière
cette technologie. On va passer sur les
enjeux géopolitiques juste après la
question que je vais vous poser.
Est-ce que l'IA peut administrer
la complexité et l'intrication de nos
sociétés mieux que nos politiques et
est-ce qu'on va confier l'administration
de nos sociétés à de l'intelligence
artificielle ? Comment cette
intelligence artificielle aura été
entraînée ? Qui aura pissé sa ligne de
code juste avant ? Avec quel biais ?
Quels sont les risques de ça ? Bah,
d'abord pour commencer euh on est déjà
dans ce que vous décrivez puisque euh je
j'ai pu me rendre pour mes travaux en
Estonie qui est un état très avancé en
matière de i-administration, même l'un
l'un des états les plus avancés au
monde. Et je repense au propos d'Edouard
Philippe,
ex-premier ministre français expliquant
que l'exemple estonien est remarquable
et que nous français devons suivre et de
facto nous le suivons puisqueen fait
notre administration est toujours plus
une i administration cf les maisons de
service que l'on déploie partout
maintenant en France pour pouvoir aider
les Français à s'y retrouver dans tous
les services numériques plétoriques
qu'offre l'administration française.
Donc c'est au service d'une forme de
fluidité. On voit cela également euh
au service de la transition écologique.
Donc on entend commence à entendre un
débat, un discours que j'ai vu sur Chine
euh faisant le lien tirant des
corrélations entre la numérisation
accrue de la gestion des villes
et la capacité de d'IA et du numérique à
protéger l'environnement de ces villes.
Je m'explique. En Chine à Pékin, les
villes émetent l'activité humaine émet
du CO2, émet des particules fines. Et
UNIA, déployé par Microsoft il y a
quelques années, a dit "Mais en fait
moi, je suis capable à 3 jours de
prédire la météo, la direction des vents
notamment les centrales à charbon du
roubeil voisin qui pourrai en fait venir
finalement mettre Pékin sous un sous un
sous un nuage de pollution. Mais
l'activité également du BTP qui fait que
ça génère des particules fines,
l'activité de du trafic sur les 6 ou se
périphériques contre Pékin. Et en fait à
3 jours, je sais qu'on va
on se dirige vers un pic de pollution et
moi intelligence artificielle je vous
dis à vous administrer mais aussi les
les les les comment dirais-je les les
administrateurs qui gèrent la ville de
Pékin. Voilà pour les trois prochaines
prochaines journées exactement ce que
vous devez faire. Donc vous appuyez sur
un bouton, vous laissez l'IA vous dire
exactement quoi faire pour pouvoir gérer
au mieux ces sources d'émission de de
CO2 et autres particules fines et éviter
le pic euh de de CO2 et la fameuse Air
Apocalypse dont on parle souvent à Pékin
et Microsoft de se vanter de dire mais
en fait ça fonctionne. Donc on voit pour
répondre à votre point ou pour prendre
un exemple concret de votre point
comment en fait la numérisation de nos
sociétés et notamment de
l'administration peut se mettre au
service en tout cas c'est clamé comme
tel d'une baisse des éisions de CO2 dans
des zones très très concentrées de
population très concentré pour le
meilleur si j'en jug l'aptitude des
habitants de Pékin à supporter les pics
de pollution. On va plus loin puisque on
peut faire ça. Pourquoi est-ce que on
projetterait pas cette capacité de Lia à
me dire pour les trois prochaines
journées, les 72 prochaines heures ce
que je peux faire ? Pourquoi est-ce
qu'on le projetterait pas aux 10
prochaines années ? Pourquoi est-ce
qu'on le projetterait pas aux 100
prochaines années ? La transition
écologique, baisser lesion les émissions
de CO2, c'est excessivement complexe. Ça
requiert des tas de données que mon
cerveau, mon petit cerveau d'humain,
n'est pas capable de processer pour
reprendre un anglicisme tout seul. Je ne
peux pas mettre face- à face ou en tout
cas faire interagir dans mon cerveau la
complexité de cette transition qui
implique de réfléchir au transport, donc
la façon dont je me déplace, la façon
dont je dont je don qu'est-ce que je
bois, la façon dont je m'alimente, euh
les la façon dont j'utilise mes outils
informatiques et ainsi de suite. Et en
fait seul UNI pourrait général propose
certains technophiles technositionnistes
pourraient proposer pourraient en fait
fournir des solutions. Donc si je suis
capable d'acquérir suffisamment de
données, de les faire tourner enfin de
de faire tourner en apprentissage
profond des algorithmes qui apprennent
sur ces états états oct et bien en fait
je suis en mesure de mettre en œuvre de
de créer une IA générale espère
certains, je sais pas si cet IA générale
existera d'ailleurs, mais qui en fait me
dirait à 100 ans voilà exactement ce
qu'il faut faire et j'ai j'ai parlé à
ces personnes qui pensent à ça. Mais ça
veut dire quoi concrètement ? Bah ça
veut dire qu'en fait de quoi serais-je
responsable demain si j'ai donné mandat
aux machines d'être maître et possesseur
de la nature en lieu et place de l'homme
? Si j'ai décidé de me déresponsabiliser
de la conduite environnementale d'une
société pour 10 15 20 100 prochaines
années au service de machine dont je ne
comprends pas forcément d'ailleurs le
fonctionnement. A-telle enseigne que ce
sujet a donné lieu à un symposium à
Oxford en 2019 où des chercheurs se sont
rassemblés pour dire mais quel serait le
futur d'un monde dans lequel on a accédé
à cette idée que on allait confier la
politique écologique d'une société à des
intelligences artificielles dont on
n'est pas forcément capable très bien de
comprendre pourquoi elles ont pris cette
décision là ? Quelle responsabilité
demain ? Est-ce que je suis parfaitement
certain que cette n'est pas en train de
vouloir détruire l'homme sur la planète
? Parce qu'après tout, si vous lui
donnez mandat de protéger la planète,
elle peut peut-être vouloir se
débarrasser de celui qui nuit à la
planète. Donc ça pose des questions
philosophiques extrêmement passionnantes
mais qui se posent aujourd'hui de façon
très théorique mais qui se pose dans les
universités, certaines universités
Oxford. Est-ce que finalement l'IA est
une bonne façon d'administrer nos
sociétés demain ?
Est-ce que vous avez rencontré quelques
politiques pour discuter de ces sujets
là ?
Non, pas tant que ça. Sur mon premier
livre, oui, sur les questions de de
d'impact écologique de la de des
technologies vertes. Oui. Sur la partie
numérique, j'ai rencontré quelques
sénateurs qui avaient produit la fameuse
loi RINE dont je vous ai parlé en 2021,
la loi sur la responsable pour la la
réduction de l'empreinte
environnementale du numérique.
quelques députés extrêmement spécialisés
sur la question, mais d'une manière
générale, le sujet est pas vraiment dans
l'air du temps. Je dirais, je pense que
le politique n'a pas nécessairement
envie de se saisir massivement de ces
enjeuxl. Donc non, je dirais non.
Quelle perception vous avez des boîtes
qui développent ce type d'ar
sans citer de nom, hein,
si vous voulez.
Encore une fois, enfin, on a évoqué ces
mots-là, mais nous sommes dans un
imaginaire de puissance et de
croissance, hein. Donc aujourd'hui,
je je
quand l'imaginaire part se fait face à
la réalité, qu'est-ce qui se passe quand
la réalité est beaucoup plus dure que
l'imaginaire de ce discours de on va
sauver les bébés f, on va sauver la
planète, on va sauver tout ça. C'est une
réalité qui est encore difficilement
palpable parce que euh aujourd'hui un
centre de données, qui l'a vu ? Qui est
rentré dans un centre de données ? Pas
grand monde. Ça se trouve euh dans les
banlieux, des grandes villes,
on les voit pas.
Il y en a à Paris, hein.
Il y en a à Paris, dans le centre de
Paris, notamment dans le sentier. Il y
en a aussi surtout dans la pleine
commune, dans le nord de Paris, enfin au
nord de Paris. Euh mais pour autant peu
d'entre nous sommes rentrés dans un
centre donné qui assistait au décollage
d'une fusée transportant euh prête à
déployer à mettre en orbite une
constellation de satellite au service
d'un service d'internet spatial. Pas
grand monde. Qui a assisté à la pose
d'un câble sous-marin au fond des mers ?
Qui visité une mine de cuivre ? qui a
visité une mine de cuivre et une mine de
charbon qui sert à produire
l'électricité euh laquelle est
nécessaire pour ensuite stocker et
rafraîchir les vidéos de char. Pas grand
monde. Donc en fait la réalité, il faut
aller se confronter à elle. Mais je veux
dire, elle s'invite pas euh facilement
dans votre petit écran et si vous
n'allez pas la chercher, elle n'est pas
là. On peut sentir internet, ça c'est ça
a une odeur internet. On peut goûter
internet, c'est un goût internet. On
peut entendre internet, on peut écouter
Internet. Mais qui c'est ça ? Qui s'est
confronté sensoriellement à la machine,
à la matrice, à l'infrastructure
internet.
Comment pour sentir internet ?
Et ben, je vais dans une mine de
graphite en Chine et je sens le graphite
qui sort de la de la mine et ce graphite
est nécessaire pour la fabrication d'une
batterie de téléphone portable. Et ben
ça a une odeur de beurre rance. C'est
très concret. Tu parlais tout à l'heure
de concret. OK, pas de problème. Mais
qui est allé dans une mine de graphite
au finfond les Yongjang dans le nord de
la Chine avec la police aux fesses ?
Parce que c'est ce qui s'est passé pour
pouvoir sentir internet. On peut
entendre Internet, on peut écouter
Internet. Internet émet un son très
particulier, c'est le son dans un centre
de données. Donc vous rentrez dans un
centre donné, moi je suis rentré dans un
centre de données en Lapony Bess.
Et ben vous avez un serveur qui siffle
mais là vous avez 1000, 10000 100000
serveurs qui sifflent. Donc vous avez
l'impression que vous êtes rentré dans
une ruche, une immense ruche, et que
vous venez de déranger 100000 abeilles
ouvrières. Donc on peut écouter le
cloud, on peut écouter internet, on peut
goûter internet, c'est un goût. Pour
moi, le goût d'internet, c'est le goût
de la
Est-ce que tu lèches les câbles le soir
? et ben je les ai léché au Portugal
puisqu'en fait quand euh les câbles en
fait les câbles sont donc 95 % de
l'information passe par des câbles
sous-marins. On a parlé de constellation
de satellite mais ce n'est que 5 % des
volumes d'information transmis euh dans
le monde. 95 % c'est sous la mer. Et
bien les câbles sont posés sous la mer.
C'est pas très épais un câble. pas tant
que ça. Non non, pas tant que ça. C'est
en fait moi j'en ai eu dans les mains,
c'est pas plus épais qu'un tuyau
d'arrosage et dedans il y a de la fibre,
il y a des paires de fibres. Et ces
paires de fibres, ben en fait c'est
l'information qui transite à travers le
monde sous forme de pulsation de
lumière. Mais il y a un mec qui recycle
la toile du net au fond des mers. Et
parce que qu'est-ce qu'on fait une au
bout de 15 ans quand le câble a vécu sa
belle vie et que finalement on le
décommissionne ? Mais en fait, on le
débranche mais on le laisse au fond des
murs. Et puis il y a un une entreprise
sud-africaine
qui recycle la toile du net au fond des
mers. C'est qu'il envoie ses bateaux au
milieu de l'Atlantique et il envoie ses
équipages de Philippins et d'Indonésiens
récupérer les câbles internet et il les
renroule, il les rembbobine sur des
milliers de kilomètres et il les ramène
à terre. Et donc là au Portugal à Porto
sur le port l'un des ports de Porto et
ben je suis sur je suis sur un quai avec
ces milliers de kilomètres de câbles qui
ont été découpés en tronçon et là je je
lâche enfin en tout cas je mets ma main
et donc internet c'est salé c'est pas
sucré donc on peut goûter internet on
peut se confronter sensoriellement à la
matière à l'infrastructure à ce qui est
aussi étéré et apparemment aussi
impalpable qu'internet conscience que
tout vient un coup mais le temps que
nous percevions consommateurs et sans
même parler de l'opérateur du centre de
données de la réalité matérielle qu'il y
ait ce cet atterrissage au sens je
dirais le plus physique du terme au
plancher des vaches où se construit une
infrastructure et bien en fait je pense
qu'il va il y a encore avoir quelques
années avant cela et du coup je crains
que nous ne soyons encore dans cette
illusion d'un déploiement d'une
infrastructure sans coût sans sans
réalité sans impact sur la santé des
hommes, sans impact sur la biodiversité
qui est en tout point faux puisque en
fait il y a cet impact impact mais que
cet impact n'est pas perceptible compte
tenu du fait que cette infrastructure on
ne peut pas la sentir, on ne peut pas la
voir, on ne peut pas la goûter, on peut
pas l'entendre sauf si on se donne la
peine de le faire.
Tu as déjà combattu dans les terres ?
Pardon, j'ai pas compris la question.
C'est normal.
Euh en terme de risque géopolitique, tu
parles de la matière. Euh quand on voit
euh euh certaines compagnies déployer un
un câble tout neuf juste en face euh
d'un pays qui est un peu fâché, le pays
des outils, euh
est-ce que tu penses que ce déploiement
d'infrastructure dans un monde de plus
en plus instable, ça nous expose pas à
des risques structurels très importants
qui mettraient à la fois notre économie
à mal si par exemple on faisait tomber
un câble internet, on faisait tomber un
data center très très important et par
effet domino ça ferait planter toute la
l'infrastructure ou par exemple Kim
Jongoun qui fait péter un missile
thermonucléaire vertical terrain
histoire de ioniser tous les satellites
qui se baladent
ou une éruption solaire ce déploiement
invasif d'une infrastructure
est-ce que ça a des risques
géopolitiques et je dirais naturels
alors je dirais on peut penser que oui
mais non sauf éruption solaire on ne
maîtrise pas les impacts d'une éruption
solaire personne ne sait ce ce qui va se
passer. La dernière réuption solaire a
eu lieu, je crois, il y a 120 ans, 130
ans.
Il y en a une pas mal il y a pas
longtemps.
Oui, récemment. Mais ça a fait des
jolies couleurs dans le ciel mais ça n'a
pas éteint tout le système électrique.
La précédente éruption solaire qui a
lieu il y a plus d'un siècle, notre
monde n'était pas électrifié comme il
est aujourd'hui. Donc personne, enfin
pas moi en tout cas est en mesure de
dire qu'est-ce qui se passera s'il y a
une éruption solaire ? Je ferme cette
parenthèse. Laisse ouverte une seule
seconde. Quand tu t'es renseigné sur
toutes ces types de technologies, il y a
personne qui t'a dit voilà on travaille
sur au cas où qui une grosse éruption
solaire. Euh
non, j'ai jamais entendu ça. OK. C'est
dommage.
J'ai jamais entendu ça. Non.
Là, alors pour revenir pour répondre à
ta question, en fait euh on peut penser
que il y a une fragilité, je dirais
systémique du réseau. D'abord, il faut
savoir que Internet, ce sont donc 3
millions de centres de stockage de
données, 3 millions à travers le monde
dont 500 qui font qui sont ce qu'on
appelle des data center hyperscale.
C'estàd c'est les plus volumineux de
tous les centres de stockage de données.
Faut savoir que le plus grand centre de
stockage de données à ma connaissance se
trouve en Chine et il certes il se il se
trouve dans un immeuble qui fait
plusieurs étages mais en gros il s'étend
sur une surface équivalente à celle de
110 terrains de football et puis après
il y a les câbles. Les câbles, c'est on
considère 1,3 million de kmè de câbles.
Donc c'est 450 câbles ou 500 câbles, on
va vers les 500 déployés qui s'ils
étaient mis bout à bout ferait
équivaudrait à 1,2 million de km de
câble. Puis après, il y a les
satellites. Euh en fait notre encore une
fois notre infrastructure repose sur
cette technologie clé et critique qu'on
appelle les câbles. Euh c'est sûr que on
peut s'attaquer à un câble, on peut
couper un câble et il y a eu des
situations qui ont été constatées
notamment au large de la Norvège
récemment de câbles de télécommunication
extrêmement stratégique qui ont été
sectionnés. Il y a des chaluier russes
là-bas, il pêchent trop profond, ça
attrape les câbles. Et il y a aussi et
ça a été une information que l'on
connaît parce qu'elle a été elle a été
dite par
partagée par
une ancienne ministre de la de la
défense Florence Parlie disant il y a un
celle qui avait un Pegasus sur son
téléphone.
Ouais. Il y a un il y a un comment on
appelle ça ? un un submarin russe qu'on
appelle qui s'appelle le Yandar et qui
se promène à la verticale de certains
câbles stratégique reluant l'Europe aux
États-Unis au large de l'Irlande. Et
donc qu'est-ce que fait ce câble là ce
pardon ce sous-marin là sinon que il
fait peut-être du repérage en vue d'une
opération de sabotage ? Vous avez parlé
des outils, tu as parlé des outils.
Effectivement, il y a des craintes
aujourd'hui qui sont exprimées quant à
la possibilité que les câbles
sous-marins qui passent par la mer rouge
et qui infiné passe par donc Jibouti mer
rouge et qui remonte par le canal de
Suèse parce que canal de Suèse c'est un
centre de transit de marchandise au sens
des conteneurs mais c'est un centre de
transit de la matière du monde numérique
qu'on appelle les données et donc vous
avez des câbles qui passent par le canal
de Suè si jamais les outils veulent
effectivement saboter je ne sais pas
s'ils en ont technologiquement les
moyens mais en tout cas il y a il y a
des craintes qui sont exprimé. Est-ce
que pour autant
on peut craindre que
la toile s'éteigne ? C'est une question
qui est compliquée parce que oui, quatre
ou cinq câbles transatlantiques qui sont
sectionnés, c'est un vrai sujet. Pour
autant, ce que l'on constate
aujourd'hui, c'est que la toile
d'araignée du net, ces câbles, elle
s'épaissit. C'est-à-dire que chaque jour
qui passe, on ne cesse de rajouter des
câbles euh à la fois des câbles qui euh
explorent des nouvelles régions du monde
ou qui relie des nouvelles régions du
monde qui n'étaient pas relié par des
câbles. On est peut-être qu'un jour par
exemple, on essaiera de relier l'Europe
au Japon en passant par des câbles qui
traverseraient
l'Arctique. Ce n'est pas encore le cas,
mais ça pourrait être le cas demain. Ou
alors en redondant certain une route
déjà existant. C'est-à-dire que les
routes des câbles sous-marins de
l'Europe aux États-Unis qui passent par
l'Atlantique et bien elles sont toujours
plus redondées. Il y a des itinerbis
terre de façon à ce que si la donnée
n'emprunte pas tel câble, elle emprunte
un autre câble. Et puis l'Europe dit "Je
suis très inquiet pour mes câbles, on
sait jamais ce qui pourrait se passer.
Donc je vais déployer une constellation
de satellite IR Square." Il y a des
sujets. Est-ce qu'on va la déployer ou
pas ? Les Allemands sont pas d'accord.
Mais Iris Square, c'est non pas la
substitution des câbles sous-marins par
de l'internet spatial, c'est l'addition.
Donc on va additionner à
l'infrastructure qui existe sous la mer
de nouvelles infrastructures dans
l'espace. Et donc en fait qu'est-ce
qu'on fait là ? Et ben en fait on
redonde et donc on sécurise. Donc il y a
pas selon moi et je n'ai jamais entendu
dans la bouche des experts de craindre
que tout d'un coup internet s'éteigne.
Je il y a trop de câbles qu'il faudrait
couper. Il y a trop de redondement de
l'infrastructure, il y a trop d'inb
d'itinrabis, il y a trop d'épaissement
de l'infrastructure pour que
véritablement le sujet d'une coupure
générale du web se produise à l'échelle
mondiale. C'est impossible. En revanche,
et ça c'est vrai, il va y avoir plus de
technologies pour aller espionner les
câbles au fond des mers, pour aller euh
voir sectionner les câbles. Tout ça, on
appelle ça le CBEL Warfare. C'est nos
armées sont ont déployé, je ont publié
une stratégie de de de guerre en fait
dans le fond des mers. le CB, les
planchers n'intéressait pas grand monde
jusque récemment et tout d'un coup, on
réalise que c'est un enjeu stratégique
parce qu'il s'y trouve notamment les
câbles. Et ça, oui, ça peut être un
sujet et je pense également qu'il va y
avoir demain des armées pour protéger
les câbles. Donc demain, je pose la
question comme ça. Est-ce que il faudra
que nous fassions la guerre au fond des
mers pour que nous puissions nous
distraire sur TikTok et les réseaux
sociaux ? Est-ce que ma distraction à
coup de vidéo de 15 secondes
dans le métro passera par plus
d'affrontements demain entre armées,
celles qui attaqueront le réseau et
celles qui défendront le réseau ? Et
soyons clair hein, je suis pas adupe,
les Français feront tout. Ils
attaqueront, ils défendront. Alors en
train de croire qu'on sera juste là pour
nous défendre. C'est pas vrai.
Évidemment qu'on sera là pour attaquer
aussi. Mais en tout cas, on voit surgir
ces enjeux de sécurité parce que encore
une fois derrière mon like, il y a tout
ça. Euh tu parlais de de
combattre sous le sous la mer comme
combattre dans les terres.
Ouais.
Euh on se retrouve maintenant avec des
essins de drones pilotés par de
l'intelligence artificielle.
On verra peut-être des essins de drones
patrouiller le long des câbles comme des
chies.
Absolument. le chien le chien le long du
mur est allemand.
Alors
la guerre et les ressources et
l'intelligence artificielle, ça donne
quoi ?
Alors déjà des essins de drone, c'est
pensé par des experts de des drones
sous-marins. Euh quand vous interrogez
les armées sur les essins de drone, ils
attendent de voir. C'est dire ça ça
coûte cher. Ouais. drone sous-marin
parce que c'était ça la question qui
patrouillerait le long des câbles. C'est
très complexe à mettre en place des
dessins de drone. Faut savoir que ça
coûte très cher un drone, que les armées
elles-mêmes ne sont pas très bien
équipées en drone par rapport à d'autres
sociétés privées qui sont en avance sur
l'armée française en en matière de de de
de enfin de comment dirais-je de de mise
à l'eau de de drone sous-marin. Donc
c'est quand même compliqué mais on peut
envisager en futur c'est ça reste
plausible dans lequel effectivement le
fond des mer sera davantage perturé par
des drones qui feront plein de choses he
qui feront pas que surveiller les câbles
ou les attaquer.
Ce peuvent être des drones autonomes ou
des drones ce qu'on appelle des ROV des
remote operating vi c'estàd qu'ils sont
guidés par un système de de
communication filaire. Ils peuvent être
au fond des mers, mais ils sont ils sont
en fait commandés sur le sur à mer en
mer via via un bateau. Voilà. En tout
cas, euh ça c'est plausible et ça ça
peut exister aussi bien pour les câbles
donc disais-je que pour euh
euh à commencer par la la cartographie
des fonds sous-marins, l'exploration de
champ de nodule polymétallique parce que
demain on ira peut-être chercher des
petites boules qui ressemblent à des
truffes au fond de l'océan Pacifique
pour pouvoir
être en ligne. Ce sont les mêmes
matériaux de la transition énergétique
et de la transition numérique que l'on
certaines sociétés espèrent aller
extraire du fond des m pour pouvoir les
mettre dans les batteries des voitures
électriques ou ou de nos téléphones
portables. Tu m'as posé une question sur
le lien entre armée, câbles et
ressources, mais j'ai oublié le sens de
armée armée. Euh euh est-ce que l'armée
euh s'intéresse à ces ces questions de
pression sur les ressources ? Tu as
creusé le truc ? Pas du tout. Est-ce
queils sécurisent par exemple leur
approvisionnement cuivre ? Est-ce qu'ils
sécurisent leur leur approvisionnement
de coton pour faire des obus ? C'est des
petites choses comme ça de bour pour des
obuts 155000 m. Penser à faire la guerre
sans coton pour les bourgs, c'est quand
même faut être un sacré crétin.
Alors déjà les armées consomment ces
matières. Faut savoir que un F35 qui est
l'équivalent du rafale consomme quantité
de matériaux.
Tu parles de l'avion qui
furtif.
Ouais
mais pas furtif sous la pluie.
J'entrerai pas dans ces considérations
là. Je suis pas assez expert pour dire à
quel point
le F35 est furtif ou pas, mais en tout
cas il est fortement consommateur de
tout un tas de matériaux, du titane
au lithium en passant par le graphite et
les terres rares. Les missiles
intelligents sont ont besoin de néodîme
pour être précisément intelligent. On a
besoin d'antimoine pour durcir le plomb
des balles et les munitions sont faites
d'antimoine qu'on va chercher aujourd'h
on a besoin de titane qu'on va chercher
en Russie. On va alors on va chercher le
titane en Russie sur tous les sur tous
les Européens. En fait les Européens
sont
large enfin substantiellement dépendants
du titane russe et en fait ils n'ont pas
le choix. Euh et en fait mais
concrètement c'est aussi pour des avions
à 320 que l'on que l'on prend le weekend
pour aller à Madrid hein. Donc
aujourd'hui
la chance parce que nous on prend pas
des A320 pour aller à Madrid le weekend
ou des A380
pour aller à Johannesbourg. Mais ce que
je veux dire c'est que c'est l'éviation
civile est fortement dépendante du
titane russe. Donc il y a un vrai sujet
de dépendance de la de l'industrie
aéronautique civile mais également du
secteur de la défense au titan russe.
Pour le moment, la Russie n'a pas
interdit n'a pas
stoppé ces exportations de titan russes
à destination de l'Europe.
Mais ni d'ailleurs non
et pas plus que de palladium ou de ou de
ou de nickel et autres matériaux
produits en Russie. euh ou de platine
russe. Tout ça continue de faire son
chemin jusqu'en jusqu'en Europe ou en
France de la même façon que nous
européens n'avons pas sanctionné euh le
titane russe. On en a besoin. La grande
question c'est qu'est-ce qui se passe si
un jour mais genre demain les Russes
décident de stopper le titan russe.
On fait des mines.
Quand on a imposé des sanctions aux
Russes sur le Camemberber pas sur le
Camemberber mais que les Russes nous ont
par effet miroir mis des sanctions sur
le fromage. Tu sais ce qu'ils ont appris
à faire les Russes avec ça ? Ils ont
appris à faire du camemberber.
Si nous ils savent que les sanctions ça
marchera pas, ils vont se dire "On va
nous mettre des sanctions, on va les
plomber pendant de an, ils vont ouvrir
des mines chez eux." Ça sert à rien.
Le truc c'est que trans
Est-ce que tu crois au fait qu'on va
réouvrir des mines chez nous ?
Le truc, c'est que transformer du lait
de vache en camember, c'est nettement
moins compliqué que transformer un un
minéral de terre rare en en aimant
permanent pour un F35. Et avant de
répondre à ta question sur les mines, on
est des français,
je finis ta question sur les armées.
Euh, les armées ont conscience de leurs
besoins matériaux. Alors, je connais
deux exemples, c'est l'armée française
et l'armée américaine. L'armée française
à la DGA, on a conscience de ses besoins
matériaux et de la cricité de ces
matériaux, notamment certaines terres
rares, le graphite
et des risques d'approvisionnement qui
pèsent sur ces approvisionnements. C'est
ce qu'on appelle la cricité. Pour
autant, je ne crois pas que mis à part
constater qu'il y a un problème,
grand-chose soit fait à la DGA
en terme d'icipation en terme
d'anticipation de ces de ces risques-là.
Après, il y a la partie américaine parce
que vraiment c'est hyper intéressant.
Les Américains, ils ont beaucoup plus de
besoins métaux parce que leurs armées
sont plus évidemment comment dirais-je,
ils dépensent davantage dans leurs
armées que nous. Donc
c'est mal formulé.
C'est mal formulé. dit plutôt, ils ont
besoin d'une grosse armée pour protéger
le dollar et protéger leurs intérêts
extérieurs.
Le Pentagone se soucie vraiment
d'approvisionnement en cobalt, en terre
rare et en antimoine pour ne citer que
ces matériaux. Les chinois aussi,
il y a une vraie politique du
département de la défense américain, le
DOD, pour l'approvisionnement et la
sécurisation d'un talon de ces
matériaux. Donc oui, les armées sont sur
le coup et oui, les armées euh
participent de alors à différentes de
différentes manières de la réouverture
de mines sur le territoire américain.
Les Chinois ont également besoin de ces
matériaux. L'avantage, c'est que ils en
produisent une bonne partie sur leur
propre sol et que quand ils ne les
produisent pas, ils vont les chercher
chez les autres. Et ils ont toute une
diplomatie minière qui s'étend jusqu'en
Amérique latine, en Afrique, qui
consiste à aller chercher en fait ces
matériaux. Mais ça vaut pour le cobalt
euh du Congo Kinshasa qui sert pour les
industries de défense dans de faibles
proportions, surtout pour les batteries
voitures électriques, mais qui sont
sécurisés par la Chine. Et donc la Chine
a accès à ces matériaux euh de façon
plus euh sécurisée que les pays
occidentaux. Vient la question qui a été
posée qui est celle de savoir est-ce
qu'on réouve des mines dans nos propres
pays ? sont des mines qui pourraient
servir à la fois pour
les technologies vertes, pour les
voitures électriques, mais des mines
également qui serviraient pour les
technologies numériques puisque ces deux
transitions utilisent les mêmes
matériaux. Euh, il y a un
sujet d'actualité qui est évoqué en
France, c'est l'ouverture d'une mine de
lithium dans l'allié. Donc, c'est une
mine qui serait ouverte en 2027-202
qui produirait du lithium et qui serait
opéré par une entreprise française
Iméris.
C'est hyper intéressant ce qui se passe
là parce qu'en fait c'est la première
fois que la question de la
relocalisation
de la production minière sur le
territoire européen se pose au sens je
dirais physique du terme. C'est-à-dire
jusque maintenant, je pouvais dire je
veux de l'électrique mais je laisse les
Chinois et les Congolais et les
Boliviens produire à ma place où je veux
un téléphone portable et je veux l'IA et
du chat GPT mais de toute façon il y a
un coût matériel qui est assumé par un
autre. Sauf que là, tout d'un coup, le
sujet, il est porté sur un nouveau front
au sens physique géographique du terme
qui est l'allié. Et là, tout d'un coup,
ça crée debat. Donc, vous avez des
riverins qui disent "Non mais attendez,
vous êtes sympa, mais vous allez creuser
plus profondément pour faire du verre ou
faire du dématérialisé.
Euh il y a un véritable sujet, donc il y
a les débats et la mine est plutôt
partie pour ouvrir mais peut-être
qu'elle n'ouvrira pas parce que il y a
des sujet autour par exemple de la
consommation d'eau de cette mine de
lithium et tout n'est pas clair autour
des impacts environnementaux de cette
mine et ça nous place complètement face
à nos contradictions puisque je veux
toutes ces technologies qui sont toutes
proposées dans un même package narratif
si je puis proposer cette expression
C'est-à-dire celle on va faire mieux
avec plus de croissance en produisant et
en consommant moins. Le monde des
technologies vertes et le monde des
technologies numériques. Ce sont deux
familles de technologies qui se
superposent, qui s'accompagnent au
service de la croissance tout en ayant
l'illusion que tout cela va générer
moins d'impact. Et tout d'un coup euh et
bien en fait la mine d'Iméris,
elle est saine et elle est pédagogique
parce qu'elle nous force à regarder en
face les considérations matérielles de
notre monde plus vert et plus
dématérialisé et à nous positionner par
rapport à ça. Est-ce qu'une mine peut
ouvrir la mine d'imeris dans l'allié ?
Moi, je le souhaite pour ces raisons que
je viens d'évoquer pour être cohérent
avec nous-même pour sortir de
l'hypocrisie. Donc moi, j'espère qu'elle
va ouvrir mais derrière la mine
d'Iméris, il y a quoi après ? le BRGM,
le bureau des ressources géologiques et
minières, nos géologues nous apprennent
que il y a en France 43 sites d'intérêt
pour l'extraction du lithium. Est-ce
qu'on va ouvrir 43000 de lithium ? Et
puis derrière le lithium, il y a quoi ?
du cuivre, du mangise, du cobalt, des
terres rares, du fer, du phosphate. Ce
sont potentiellement des centaines de
mines qu'il faut ouvrir dans le monde et
pourquoi pas en Europe.
Si je dis à l'éle lecteur dans le pays
que l'on voit actuellement, très
éruptif, que on va ouvrir des mines à
tout bout de champ, vous comprenez bien
que ça va pas être facile. Donc je suis
assez inquiet non pas de la possibilité
d'ouvrir une seule mine, mais je suis
plus inquiet de la capacité de de
l'acceptabilité sociale en France et en
Europe autour de l'ouverture de
centaines de mines. Parce que c'est bien
de ça dont il est question.
Quand Marine Le Pen parle des
technologies de transition écologique,
tuas tu as écouté ?
Bah en fait Marine Le Pen, elle vient de
dire que les technologies vertes c'était
pas propre et et que du coup, il fallait
peut-être pas faire la transition
énergétique que l'on fait actuellement
ou en tout cas peut-être freiner. Je
voudrais pas trahir ses propos, mais en
tout cas, elle s'est positionnée
récemment contre le déploiement des
technologie verte ou en tout cas pas à
ce rythme là parce que c'est pas propre.
En fait, c'est une réponse, enfin c'est
un propos qui est profondément
démagogique à un sujet qui est complexe
parce que en fait c'est compliqué cette
histoire de de technologie verte et
numérique qui sont fortement
matérielles.
C'est le dire, ça ne veut pas dire que
je suis contre la transition énergétique
et contre la transition numérique.
Évidemment qu'il faut déployer un
numérique intelligent. Évidemment qu'il
faut déployer une transition écologique
et les transition de la technologie
verte de façon intelligente. Mais le
sujet c'est pas de le freiner. La
complexité du message, c'est qu'il faut
dénoncer ces ces effets pervers, ses
revers, mais pour les corriger et en vue
de l'accélérer.
La transition énergétique, c'est une
transition où on a juste proposé de
remplacer des bagnoles thermiques par
des bagnoles électriques et des
centrales à charbon par des panneaux
solaires en disant "Tant que tu fais ça,
tu auras sauvé les pandas chinois, les
perroquets brésiliens et les lémuriens
malgaches
et les bébés f." Non, c'est pas ça.
C'est trop simple. Mais il faut se
lancer dans cette transition qui est une
transition minière et immédiatement
rentrer dans la transition énergétique
2.0. Et la transition énergétique 2.0,
c'est comment est-ce que je vais faire
pour mitiger ces impacts ? Comment
est-ce que je vais faire pour
relocaliser la mine un coût acceptable
pour tout le monde ? Comment est-ce que
je vais faire pour aller chercher le
minerais dans d'autres pays mais en
s'assurant que les standards de
production de ces pays sont cohérents
avec les miens pour que mon consommateur
en retour en France accepte le minerai
et donc la technologie verte, la bagnole
parce qu'il sait que les minerais en
amont de la chaîne de valeur ont été
extraits de façon respectueuse. Comment
est-ce que je déploie une nouvelle
géopolitique qui ne soit pas au service
de nouvelles guerres mais qui soit au
contraire au service de nouveaux liens
commerciaux entre nouveaux états
partenaires. Comment est-ce que je
réfléchis à la façon dont je consomme
cette technologie ? Parce que pardon
mais c'est pas tout d'avoir une B
électrique. Il y a 50 nuances de
voitures électriques.
Est-ce qu'il y a 50 nuances d'immaturité
de consommation de ressources de facto ?
Et
est-ce qu'il faut légiférer, encadrer,
avoir une société beaucoup plus, je vais
grossir le trait, mais beaucoup plus
totalitaire pour encadrer la
consommation de matière ? Est-ce que ce
qu'on nous a mis dans la tête depuis, je
dirais les années
à la sortie de la guerre 3945, comme
quoi on aurait tous deux bagnoles, qu'on
aurait deux maisons de campagne, qu'on
vivrait tous avec une armée d'esclaves
qui nous permettrait de ripailler et de
faire bombance et bamboche tout au long
de notre vie. Là, on est en train de se
faire rattraper par les réalités
physiques et minières de notre pauvre
monde. Est-ce que une société
profondément immereure avec ce type de
technologie et euh
une consommation au trans pour regarder
des vidéos de chat ou des vidéos de de
gens qui se cassent la figure ou qui
leur arrivent des petites mésaventures ?
Est-ce qu'il faut pas implémenter dans
notre société soit de la maturité, soit
de la réglementation coercitive ?
Il y a 50 nuances de technologie verte,
c'est compliqué mais la transition 2.0
dans laquelle on est, c'est la
transition qui consiste à dire une fois
qu'on a ces technologies, comment est-ce
qu'on fait pour mieux sourcer les
matériaux ? Comment est-ce qu'on fait
pour mieux les consommer ? Et et c'est
là que Marine Le Pen est profondément
démagogue parce qu'elle vous dit il faut
l'arrêter, il faut pas l'arrêter, il
faut l'accélérer en faisant un saut de
conscience qui s'additionne au saut
technologique.
Derrière se pose la question que tu
poses.
En fait,
on voit surgir des limites. On voit
surgir des limites alors qui peuvent
être des limites géologiques. C'est qu'
aujourd'hui on constate que certains
calculs disent à l'horizon 2050, on aura
consommé 70 80 % des ressources de
cuivre et de cobalt pour la transition
énergétique. Et puis après, on voit
surgir d'autres limites et ça va
exactement venir à la question de
l'acceptabilité de tout cela et de type
de de régime qui peut accompagner cette
transition. Mais on constate des limites
qui peuvent être des limites
psychologiques. Je les appelle comme ça.
C'est-à-dire que le minerai est
disponible. On sait que on peut creuser
là et qu'on va on extraire de ce
gisement du cuivre, du cobal, du nickel.
Pour autant euh il y a un coût
écologique, il y a un coût énergétique,
il y a un coût euh social, il y a un
coûpt politique, il y a un coût
géopolitique qui est insupportable et
nos opinions poussent pour un meilleur
encadrement de la production du métal.
Et il faut que le métal de demain ne
soit pas juste métal X, il faut que ce
soit un métal éthique. Et si ce métal
n'est pas éthique, et ben en fait on
n'ira pas l'extraire ou en tout cas s'il
est extrait, on n'ira pas l'acheter. Ce
que je vais vous dire, c'est qu'en fait
on a
besoin de métal mais on n pas le désir
du métal parce que le métal c'est
toujours associé à la à la saleté et que
en fait les limites à la transition
c'est celles que sont ce sont les
standards que la société impose à la
façon dont on extrait ces minerais. Et
si jamais on se met des standards qui
sont tellement élevés en terme
d'extraction éthique en respectuant les
bébés f, les pandas, les perroquets et
les lémuriens, ben en fait peut-être
qu'on va pas pouvoir extraire.
Et les riverins de la mine
et surtout les livrins de la mine
évidemment, j'ai évidemment et je parle
pas encore de la déforestation et de la
biodiversité, de l'eau et cetera et
cetera. Là où ça pose un problème, c'est
qu'en fait on a quand même besoin de ces
métaux et que si on veut être plus vert
et plus dématérialisé, il va falloir
creuser plus profondément. Quelle
société dans le monde d'aujourd'hui a
été capable de faire accepter à sa
population, enfin l'aversement accepté,
mais d'imposer à sa population d'avoir
une production minière qui soit
cohérente avec ses ambitions vertes et
numériques. La Chine et la Chine est un
état totalitaire. Donc en fait est-ce
que on peut imposer un renouveau minier
qui est consubstantiel à la transition
énergétique à des sociétés de gens qui
expriment leur désactor sur TikTok à
longueur de journée ? Donc évidemment
que c'est une question qui est immense.
Alors là, vous avez un enjeu passionnant
et un discours passionnant qui est porté
notamment par la Russie de Vladimir
Poutine qui dit "La transition
énergétique, elle peut se faire que dans
des états totes."
Ça a été dit ça ? Mais oui oui, ça a été
dit par les conseillers de c'était dans
politique internationale il y a quelques
mois, politique internationale est un
est un est un trimestriel et l'un des
conseillers euh de de Poutine dont le
nom m'échappe, euh celui dont la fille a
été euh tuée dans un attentat disait
précisément ça. Il faisait un lien
direct entre un régime totalitaire
capable
propagandiste euh comment il s'appelait
? Euh le barbu là.
Ouais, ça doit être lui. J'avoue que je
ne sais plus.
Ouais, je vois. il disait euh on ne peut
imposer une telle radicalité de
transition parce que c'est une
transition qui est quand même assez
radicale vu le temps dont on dispose
pour la réaliser qu'à des peuples qui
soient soumis quoi. Enfin, il l'a pas
dit exactement comme ça, mais c'était le
sens de son message. Euh
la Chine montre au reste du monde
qu'elle est capable de faire une
transition minière et quelque part elle
la transition écologique est une
transition est un combat de valeur.
C'est un combat entre les valeurs
chinoises qui disent "Vous voulez
creuser plus profondément et il faut
accélérer cette cette extraction minière
pour que les intrants matériels dans nos
économies, les intrans métalliques
soient suffisants pour pouvoir supporter
le basculement vers l'électrique." Et
ben très bien, bah dans ce cas-là, il va
falloir creuser, mais il va falloir
qu'on vous l'impose. Face à ça, vous
avez une autre philosophie et donc c'est
notre régime, le régime totalitaire qui
est le mieux à même de réaliser cette
transition écologique. Et moi, régime
totalitaire, je prouve que je peux faire
le faire mieux que les autres. La
preuve, c'est que j'inonde le monde de
mes minera et de mes panneaux solaires à
Bakou. Et auriez-vous en France autant
de panneaux solaires ? Est-ce que vous
auriez un taux de pénétration des
technologies solaires dans les mixes
électriques français qui serait celui-ci
si jamais je n'avais pas imposé la
transition minière à mes populations ?
Donc il y a un direct, excusez-moi de le
dire, entre une dictature et la capacité
en fin de chaîne, nous français à avoir
plus de panneaux solaires que si jamais
on avait attendu ou si que que si jamais
on avait pas produit ces minerais
nous-mêmes. Je le fais je l'explique de
façon volontairement brute comme ça mais
pour faire ce lienlà. Ce qui ne veut pas
dire que je pense exactement ce que je
dis. Je vous dis juste aussi en partie
qu'est-ce qui se passe dans la tête d'un
hiérarque chinois. Face à ça, vous avez
une autre philosophie qui consiste à
dire la transition écologique, elle ne
peut être réalisée que si elle est
acceptée par tout le monde. Et c'est
exactement le sens de la convention
qui a été réalisée au CE récemment en ce
sens qu'on a mis autour de la table un
panel représentatif de l'opinion
publique pour dire on va se mettre tous
d'accord autour d'un avenir d'un
objectif d'un avenir écologique partagé
et on va se fixer des objectifs et on va
proposer et et le sens du gouvernement
c'est de dire on va suivre ensuite ces
préconisations là préconisations qui ont
plus ou moins été voir pas du tout enfin
mal été suivies mais en tout cas c'est
cette idée de dire On ne peut le faire
ensemble, on ne peut que le faire
ensemble. Et donc, il faut que cette
transition soit démocratique. Et c'est
la condition d'une acceptabilité
sociale. Parce que quoi ? C'est quoi les
gilets jaunes ? C'est la première
jaquerie de la transition énergétique.
Tu sais comment on appelle ça nous ? On
appelle ça les canaris dans la mine de
la mondialisation.
Moi, je dirais que c'est les premiers
troubles sociaux de la transition
énergétique. C'est le moment où une
franche de la population française est
sortie dans la rue avec les violences
que l'on sait parce que on leur a dit
vous allez payer plus cher votre diesel.
Pas pas les violences des gilets jaunes.
Bah ça a été violent sur les Champs
élysées quand même.
Oui, sur les champsélysées mais des
gilets jaunes et bornis et nuclé. Les
violences au sanchent large.
Les violences au sechent large. Je je
suis pas là pour euh pour je j'explique
que on leur a dit on va prendre 3
centimes à la pompe, je sais plus
combien c'était, on va vous taxer plus
mais pour pouvoir financer davantage le
déploiement de technologie verte. Donc
ça a été la question de savoir comment
est-ce que je répartis l'effort et
notamment un effort fiscal. Et il y a eu
une expression de colère dans la rue qui
en fait touchait à l'enjeu de savoir
comment est-ce que on serait parti un
effort notamment un effort financier. Et
je crois vraiment que si jamais on n'est
pas capable d'emmener tout le monde,
pardon de ce terme que j'aime pas en
fait inclusif, mais si jamais il y a pas
une forme d'inclusivité dans la façon
d'emmener tout le monde vers ses choix
plus verts mais aussi vers la
répartition d'un effort y compris
fiscal, cette transition va coûter très
cher et bien en fait on n'y arrivera pas
sans justice sociale
et sans justice évidemment sociale et et
ça passe par la question de savoir qui
en paye le coût et et cf ce qui s'est
passé avec la la crise des gilets
jaunes. Donc encore une fois, je ne fais
que répondre à cette question en disant
il y a deux façons de voir la chose. Il
y a une façon radicale et dictatoriale
de voir la chose en disant on ne peut
pas faire autrement qu'en l'imposant par
le haut de façon hiérarchique avec une
forme de violence étatique qui nous
l'impose. Et de l'autre façon, une autre
façon de faire qui est plus bottom up
pour reprendre un anglicisme qui
consiste à associer davantage l'opinion
publique parce que c'est consubstantiel
régime démocratique et que c'est que
comme ça qu'on pourra le faire. J'ose
espérer que nos sociétés euh peuvent
réaliser la chose de façon démocratique
parce que face à ça, il y a des États
qui aujourd'hui promuve une autre façon
de gouverner les foules et qui se
servent de leur expérience en matière de
transition énergétique pour pouvoir
justifier des modèles non démocratiques.
Tu veux creuser un peu plus le sujet
au sens rigux ou au sens propre ?
Euh
comme tu veux. J'ai enfin j'ai dit ce
qui me paraissait être les messages
importants autour de ça.
Question internet,
je la prend la première qui passe. Dans
les limites de la croissance, les
auteurs construisent un modèle
informatique simplifié du monde pour en
étudier les principales variables en
fonction de la population, de la
production industrielle,
de l'exploitation des ressources.
L'intelligence artificielle
pourrait-elle amener à construire une
supervision de ce modèle pour déterminer
les meilleures voies pour l'humanité et
ainsi déciter de nos politiques
industrielles, sociales et écologiques ?
On abordait un peu en début d'interview
cette questionlà. Oui oui, c'est ça
c'est que ça ça fait penser à cette idée
que une générale forte
comme dans Marvel
voilà est capable de d'envisager. Alors
je je ce qu'il y a enfin ce qui est sûr
c'est que
aujourd'hui on a besoin de modèle
prédictif et on fait de la prédiction.
C'est-à-dire qu'on et ça c'est vrai dans
des universités françaises. On on
réfléchit et on prévoit on prédit.
Alors, c'est très imprécis parce que on
ne sait pas quelles seront les
technologies du quotidien en 10 ans,
mais on essaie de se projeter dans un
futur à 10, 15, 20 ans, 30 ans et de
dire voici quels seront nos besoins
compte tenus notre mode de vie, nos
besoins en produits du quotidien mais
également nos besoins en en matière
première. Et donc on on fait de la
prédiction de nos besoins et il y a des
scénarios qui sont plus ou moins
optimistes, plus ou moins pessimistes
qui permettent de de ensuite d'affiner
ces ces ces ces prévisions de
consommation de matière. Et face à ça et
bien on met la question de la capacité
de notre système productif à fournir
cette matière première. J'espère que ça
répondra à la question. Mais en gros euh
vous avez face à ces besoins d'abord un
système qui produit, un système
productif qui produit et qui produit
aussi parce que bah on extrait du sol
mais parce que on substitue certains
matériaux plus dilués dans les courses
terrestres, plus rares par des matériaux
moins rares. Donc du coup ça permet de
nouvelles disponibilités de matériaux.
On substitue et on recycle. et recycler,
ça veut dire réutiliser une matière qui
a déjà été utilisée. On la remet dans le
produit suivant et de facto, on limite
euh si si on peut le faire notre retour
à la mine parce qu'en fait on on
retourne chez le recycleur plutôt qu'à
la mine. Face à ça, il y a des limites.
Il y a des limites, je dirais, que
j'appellerais biophysique. C'est-à-dire
aujourd'hui, il faut creuser toujours
plus profondément pour obtenir la même
quantité de matière. par exemple dans
les mines de cuivre. J'en discutais avec
Marc Tiffanie qui est un l' un ancien
PDG de Angloamerican, une grande
entreprise minière qui extrait du cuivre
et qui me disait 100 ans plus tard en
2020, je crois que j'ai discuté avec lui
en 2020 2021 par rapport à 1920 et bien
en 2020 21 il faut extraire 14 fois plus
de cuivre non il faut extraire 14 fois
plus de matière première de de de roche
d'une mine pour obtenir à l'arrivée la
même quantité de cuivre par rapport à
1920 parce que bah le gisement c'est
appauvri donc c'est ce qu'on appelle
biophysique. Mais la m biophysique c'est
la disponibilité de l'eau. C'est de dire
mais en fait vous n'avez pas assez on
manque d'eau dans le désert des Takama
Chili. Là on extrait notamment du cuivre
et
tu as déjà été là-bas ?
Ouais. Enfin non, moi j'y suis pas
personnellement allé mais j'ai travaillé
là-dessus mais on manque d'eau. Il y a
pas assez d'eau dans les affifères et
donc faut aller chercher l'eau en fait
dans les s Pacifiques. Mais est-ce qu'on
va manquer de cuivre ou est-ce qu'on va
manquer d'eau pour extraire le minerai ?
Tout ça c'est les limites biophysiques.
Après vous avez des limites du système
je dirais productif lui-même. Est-ce que
on a assez d'électricité ? Est-ce que on
a assez d'eau industrielle, c'est-à-dire
de l'eau qui est dessanisée qui
proviennent de l'océan Pacifique ?
Est-ce qu'on a assez de main d'œuvre ?
Est-ce que on a assez de logistique ?
Est-ce que les systèmes logistiques, les
les les flux logistiques sont assez
perfectionnés ? Est-ce qu'on a assez de
propriétés intellectuelles ? elle peut
être tenue par un autre pays plutôt que
moi. Après, vous avez des limites qui
sont économiques, par exemple guerre
commerciale avec des États qui décident
de cesser leurs exportations ou
d'imposer des États des des quotas aux
exportations ou des taxes aux
exportations ou à l'importation de
métaux. Ce qui fait que ça crée en fait
des disruptions dans la fluidité de des
matériaux. Et la dernière limite, c'est
une limite qui est plus sociopolitique,
ce sont les normes ESG.
J'impose des normes environnementales,
sociales et de gouvernance à la
production de minerais, mais mes normes
deviennent de plus en plus strictes
parce que les opinions européenne sont
plus exigeantes quant à l'origine du
minerais. Mais du coup, ben à un moment,
ça devient tellement strict qu'en fait,
je peux plus extraire du miner. Ces
quatre formes de limite, elles
s'intègrent dans les modèles. Et donc
c'est là ça répond à la question. On
fait des modèles qui intègrent ce type
de variable là et qui mettent face à la
la puissance du système productif et à
sa réinvention par la grâce de la
technologie. et ben qui je dis la grâce
entre guillemets évidemment et bien
mettre en face toutes ces limites-là et
là vous avez besoin de faire tourner des
modèles algorithmique pour pouvoir et
bien être capable de répondre à la
question de savoir si en 2050 vous aurez
assez de cuivre, vous aurez assez de
nickel ou de cobalt mais même de métaux
très abondants comme par exemple de fer
pour vos pour vos besoins. Et donc oui,
il faut de l'IA pour ça. Donc l'IA
peut-être bien utilisé.
Question internet. Que pense l'invité de
la Smart des Smart Grids pour optimiser
la production consommation locale
d'énergie entre parenthèses renouvelable
ou pas ? Alors, on a on a on a un peu
traité ce point tout à l'heure. Il y a
pas de transition écologique sans
transition numérique. C'est-à-dire que
j'ai besoin du smart grid, du réseau
intelligent pour faire ma transition
énergétique. Concrètement, je le disais
rapidement tout à l'heure, il faut
les les technologies vertes, les
solaires éoliens sont intermittentes.
Comment je fais pour en fait faire en
sorte que l'offre et la demande se
rencontre en temps réel ? Il faut en
fait du pilotage informatique des
réseaux. C'est du Smart Grid et c'est la
Smart City. Et la Smart City, c'est pas
tout à fait inutile non plus. On on
bien que j'ai énormément de de de
critiques à à émettre à l'encontre de la
Smart City, euh pour autant la Smart
City c'est quoi ? C'est bah en fait
quand je suis pas là chez moi et que bah
il tout d'un coup le soleil vient
inonder mon salon, automatiquement les
rideaux se baissent et en fait ça permet
de conserver une forme de fraîcheur chez
moi et donc du coup de moins faire
tourner la climatisation. Donc dis façon
aussi simpliste, c'est pas du tout
inutile la Smart City, c'est un rêve de
l'industrie qui rêve de déployer la
Smart City partout au service de
l'optimisation.
Donc j'espère que ça répond à la
question. Ah, le petit capteur de
domotique pour fermer le rideau dans 2
millions d'appartements, ça fait ouvrir
combien de mines ça ?
Exactement. Et donc face à ça, il y a en
fait ce qu'on appelle bah en fait c'est
le métabolisme urbain. En fait les
urbanistes, il pensent en terme de
métabolisme urbain. En fait il pensent
la ville comme un corps. C'est-à-dire
que moi, je suis un corps qui consomme
de la matière et qui ensuite la digère
et qui la rejette sous une autre forme.
Pardon de le dire comme ça, mais c'est
pareil pour une ville. Je euh consomme
de la ressource et en fait je digère
cette ressource comme un corps. Je
digère de l'eau, je la consomme de
l'électricité et aussi de la matière.
Tu sais ce que c'est un fatberg ?
Non, c'est une grosse montagne.
C'est un gros bouchon de graisse dans
les égouts.
Non, je connaissais pas le terme de
Fatberg. Mais en tout cas, le
métamolisme urbain, c'est cette idée de
se dire en fait ma smart city, si je
regarde juste son comment dirais-je son
pédigré environnemental
à l'intérieur des limites du périf, je
vais plutôt voir des effets positifs
parce que elle va mieux fluidifier
les flux de mieux gérer, mieux
administrer les flux d'hommes de bien et
d'énergie. Voilà. et de bobo.
Mais si je regarde tout ce qu'elle
consomme et si je considère qu'en fait
les véritables limites de ma Smart City
se trouvent en fait au-delà du
périphérique jusque dans les mines de
métritique chinois dans lesquelles on
extrait le cuivre qui en fait termine
dans les fameux outils domotiques de mon
appartement. Si je considère que les le
véritable la véritable frontière de ma
Smart City, c'est le centre de stockage
de données qui s'ouvre peut-être à des
centaines de kilomètres de là, mais qui
en fait œuvre comme un un un un un
serveur de enfin dans lequel il y a des
serveurs qui stockent les données de la
smart city. Et bien en fait si j'ad si
je contrebalance un gain par l'ensemble
de ces coûts négatifs et bien en fait
tout d'un coup j'ai une appréciation de
mon métabolisme qui est plus nuancé. Et
c'est vrai que on peut penser que la
smart city euh
génère des bénéfices mais qu'elle génère
aussi des coûts. Et c'est très difficile
de savoir si le si le comment dirais-je
si tout cela c'est plutôt bénéfique ou
moins bénéfique pour l'environnement. Ça
dépend des villes en fait. Il faut
regarder, faut faire du cas par cas.
Euh, question de pas internet. Le nickel
en Nouvelle-Calonie représente 35 % des
ressources mondial. Pensez-vous nous
réexpliquer l'importance de l'île pour
un pays comme la Chine et faire le lien
du rôle qu'elle aurait pu avoir avec les
événements récents ?
Alors, alors le nickel est un métal de
la transition énergétique. Il faut du
nickel pour la transition énergétique
euh mais pour la transition numérique
aussi. Euh la Nouvelle-Calédonie est un
important producteur euh de ce métal.
Euh le problème de la Nouvelle
Calédonie, c'est qu'en fait ces coûts de
production du nickel sont élevés. Ils
sont très élevés pour des tas de
raisons. Ils sont élevés. L'une des
principales raisons, c'est que le coût
de l'énergie,
on a des mines en France
en Nouvelle, on a des mines pas en
France métropolitaine mais on a des
mines
la Nouvelle Calonie, c'est la France
dans nos territoires d'automè et
communauté d'autres mer. L'électricité,
enfin le le coût d'énergie en
Nouvelle-Conie est hors de prix. Il y a
par ailleurs des troubles sociaux autour
de sites miniers qui font que il y a des
concessions minières qui ne peuvent pas
opérer et du coup vous avez d'une façon
générale un coût de production de la
matière qui est plus élevé qu'ailleurs.
Qui est le premier producteur de
mineraines nickel de la planète ? En
réalité c'est l'Indonésie. L'Indonésie
et les Philippines également.
Ça pourrait venir de l'Indonésie. Et
donc en fait ce qui se passe c'est que
l'Indonésie
produit de façon historique. C'est c'est
une filière qui est pas tant historique
que ça mais c'est une filière qui monte
en puissance ces dernières années.
Est-ce qu'il a décidé de tuer ses
concurrents ? Et c'est exactement ça qui
se passe. Et en fait, j'allais venir à
ça, c'estàd qu'en fait ce que fait la
l'Indonésie, c'est que elle
produit le minerais, elle le raffine sur
place mais elle l'envoie également
beaucoup en Chine. Et donc il y a un
trium virate, Chine,
Philippine, Indonésie qui en fait est
assis sur une majorité de la production
mondiale de nickel. Je crois pouvoir
vous dire, mais je voudrais, je parle de
tête, il faudrait vérifier chiffre mais
je crois que la production minière, je
parle juste de la production de ces de
ces trois pays et de l'ordre de 60 à 70
% et je crois que c'est pareil pour le
raffinage à vérifier mais ce sont dans
ces ordres-là. Qu'est-ce que fait la la
nouvelle l'Indonésie ? L'Indonésie a
décidé de tuer le marché. En fait, elle
peut produire à des coûts qui sont plus
bas. Et donc en fait, il y a un dumping
social, il y a un dumping
environnemental qui est en fait agencé
par l'Indonésie. Pourquoi ? parce qu'en
fait ça tue ses concurrents et donc ça
ne permet pas à la Nouvelle-Calédonie de
tenir les coûts de production et plus
personne aujourd'hui ne veut en fait
payer enfin soutenir euh une production
minière néocalédonienne qui est euh bien
trop chère et qui en fait euh enfin le
coût du minerai est plus cher à la
production que euh le prix auquel on
peut le revendre. Donc en fait les
Ramettes les Glencor point que n'ont pas
d'intérêt et l'ont signifié de soutenir
la production nickel. Euh l'Indonésie
veut en fait tuer ses concurrents pour
tenir la production de nickel et pour
pouvoir ensuite euh être leader du
marché du nickel, descendre la chaîne de
valeur et produire une fin des batteries
de voitures électriques. C'est ce que
euh expriment depuis des années les
autorités indonésiennes.
Qu'est-ce que tu penses de la
dématérialisation de la monnaie ? les
les shitcoin, les bitcoins, les monoin,
les les popo coin, les alors
les dog coin.
Ah, je vais traiter la question sous un
angle
environnemental parce que c'est comme ça
que je le connais. Euh
le Bitcoin, alors c'est connu hein, ce
sont des chiffres qui datent un peu, qui
datent peut-être de 2020, faudrait les
mettre à jour, mais on considère que
c'est la consommation d'électricité d'un
pays comme l'Argentine, un pays d'une
quarantaine de millions d'habitants. Je
crois que l'Argentine, c'est 45 milli
d'habitants. Euh on considère que ce
sont les émissions de CO2 d'un pays
comme la Grèce. Euh donc en fait toutes
ces technologies, toutes ces nouvelles
monnaaies, elles peuvent avoir un une
utilité euh parce que au-delà du
Bitcoin, ce sont aussi toutes les
monnaies locales qui peuvent être des
monnaies d'échange et qui peuvent créer
du lien dans un quartier, dans une
ville, dans un village. Il en existe des
des milliers à travers le monde. quelque
fois dans dans des pays où l'inflation
est telle que la monnaie n'a plus de
valeur
instant donné, vous pouvez avoir des
monnaies virtuelles qui sont plus
stables que des monnaies en physique,
des monnaies nationales. Donc il faut
pas complètement, je dirais aujourd'hui
des enf de de faire faire le process
systématique de de ces monnaies qui
peuvent être utiles.
Néanmoins, pour connaître un petit peu
qui investit dans les Bitcoin, avoir
passé un peu de temps avec des
investisseurs de Bitcoin, c'est pas pour
ces usages là qu'on utilise le Bitcoin
majoritairement, c'est pour boursicoter.
Alors juste un détail, les les
investisseurs Bitcoin que tu as
rencontré, ils avaient une voiture verte
?
Je sais pas. Non, je sais pas. Je je
j'ai j'ai pas de
parce que nous, on a des copains
investissent en Bitcoin depuis euh 2010.
Ils ont tous une voiture verte.
Alors, on comprend pas
à quoi sert Bitcoin aujourd'hui ? À quoi
sert-il ? Il sert
quel est le l'utilité sociale
contrecarer contrecarrer la mégalomanie
des politiques ?
Bah, par peut-être plus de de
mégalomanie encore, mais je suis très
dubitatif de l'utilité sociale,
sociétale, politique de de cette de cet
outil. Euh et la question c'est
quel est enfin je dire appression quand
même le coût de des émissions de CO2 de
la consommation d'électricité de cette
euh technologie de cette monnaie
comparativement à l'utilité que ça
représente. Et je suis extrêmement
dubitatif quant à cette monnaie
virtuelle qui je vous rappelle est quand
même la première des monnaes virtuelles.
La deuxième monnaie virtuelle après le
Bitcoin, je sais plus laquelle c'est.
Est-ce que c'était pas l'étéum ? Je suis
plus sûr mais est très énormément
derrière en terme de de de de volume de
de de de de richesse
créé, échangé et cetera. Donc je suis
mon coin. Non, c'est pas la
non je sais plus. J'avoue que je suis
pas un spécialiste de ces de ces
monnaies là au point de de rentrer
là-dedans. Mais il y a un véritable
coûpt opportunité
d'opportunité à faire. On fait tous des
coûts d'opportunités dans notre vie. On
fait tous des calculs d'opportunités. se
présente à la à la présidence française.
Non, mais je veux dire de depuis depuis
l'origine de Maité, l'homme passe sa vie
à faire des choix qui sont euh guidés
par une analyse coût bénéfice de ce
qu'il fait. Et ce soir, je suis ici
parce que je considère que le temps que
je passe à vous voir vaut enfin est
contrebalancé par
ce que tu vas te faire en achetant des
livres,
le gain que je peux peut-être pour moi
mais aussi peut-être pour ceux qui nous
écoutent, celles qui nous écoutent, je
l'espère. Mais en tout cas, on fait des
copportun on fait des des analyses coûts
bénéfices. Quand on arrive sur les
questions du numérique, on ne fait plus
ces analyses là et on les fait plus pour
deux raisons. On les fait plus parce que
d'abord le numérique c'est
dématérialisé, c'est zéro impact. Donc
pourquoi faire pourquoi calculer cela ?
puisque par définition, j'ai en face du
gain que je tire d'être sur TikTok et
sur d'autres applications numériques
parfaitement respectables, aucune espèce
de référentiel euh quantifié de l'impact
environnemental que ça puisque on m'a
dit que c'était zéro impact et par
ailleurs, je vous rappelle que c'est
gratuit. Quand vous allez sur Facebook,
c'est gratuit.
Ah non, c'est pas gratuit.
Ben non, c'est pas gratuit. C'est parce
que c'est vous le produit. Donc c'est
vous le produit. Ça veut dire qu'en fait
vous payez mais en donnant des morceaux
de vous-même qu'on appelle vos données
utilisateur mais vous avez l'illusion
l'illusion que c'est gratuit. Mais donc
si c'est zéro coût financier ou en tout
cas je vis dans l'illusion que c'est
zéro coût financier. Et si vous avez
l'illusion que c'est zéro coût
écologique pourquoi faire des analyses
coût bénéfices ? Vous me posez la
question précisément du Bitcoin.
personne n'a l'idée de faire une analyse
qu'au bénéfice puisque par définition ça
participe cette c'est ça fait partie de
cet environnement numérique qui est
présenté comme étant gratuit et zéro
impact. D'où la dangerosité du discours
et du récit de la gratuité autour de ces
technologies évidemment
on parcours sup. Qu'est-ce que tu en
penses ?
Non, j'ai aucune aucun avis là-dessus.
D'accord.
Euh, est-ce que tu as trois bouquins à
conseiller à notre communauté ?
Alors, oui, j'ai euh
le dernier livre de Bruno Lemire.
Non, pas celui-ci en fait. Je pense à
deux livres. Alors, je suis au
l'avantdernier livre de Bruno Lemire
non plus. H et pas enfin en tout cas moi
j'ai deux livres à conseiller. Le
premier en fait je suis au jur d'un d'un
prix de la société des gens de lettrre
et ce prix nous avons tout récemment euh
choisi comme lauréat de ce prix. C'est
le prix le Louis et Lina Powels. Nous
avons choisi un livre de François Hand
qui est un professeur au collège de
France et ce livre s'appelle Immigration
de Point le Grand DNI. Alors là, tu te
dis OK, j'ai invité un frontiste sur mon
plateau. Pas du tout. En fait, quand on
dit immigration grand déni, on pense
évidemment que c'est une comment
dirais-je ? Ce sont des expressions
d'extrême droite pour dire vous niez
l'importance de l'immigration. En fait,
immigration de grand années de François
Eran, c'est l'inverse. Je vois que
certains l'ont lu. En fait, ça veut dire
vous n'yez, vous ne voyez pas, on ne
voit pas les réels chiffres de
l'immigration. Et donc en fait ce
chiffre, ce livre rentre en fait dans
toute la nuance de la complexité du
phénomène migratoire à l'échelle
mondiale, à l'échelle européenne, à
l'échelle française pour complètement
nous désystériser si tenté que le mot
existe autour de ces sujets-là. On en a
bien besoin par les temps qui courent et
pour nous montrer que la France n'est
pas du tout le principal pays d'accueil
européen, que il y a toute une
complexité d'appréciation de ces
phénomènes migratoires
qui et de transit et c'est hyper
intéressant le transit parce que par
exemple ce qu'on dit pas c'est que plus
de la moitié d'immigration en France
sont les étudiants venus notamment
d'Afrique de de notre zone d'influence
post-coloniale mais qui viennent étudier
en France et qui repartent à la fin de
leur séjour. Tu as les chiffres ?
Alors, je crois que c'est plus de 50 %.
Euh je crois
bah en fait c'est pas moi qui écrit le
bouquin. Autant sur le sur ce qu'on a
dit précédemment, je je m'engage sur les
chiffres. Autant ayant lu ce livre il y
a quelques temps, j'ai oublié mais je
crois et je je laisse les fact checkers
vérifier que c'est plus de 50 % de
l'immigration en France qui est une
immigration étudiante mais c'est des
étudiants qui euh pour une part
substantielle entre eux je ne connais
plus le chiffre inviter François Hand à
l'occasion sur ce sur ce fauteuil mais
repart à la fin de leur leurs études. On
parle souvent de ceux qui rentrent, on
parle pas de ceux qui sortent, on oublie
de faire le sol au passage. Donc ça
c'est un livre qui est passionnant et
qui permet en fait de remettre de la
raison, de la nuance dans ces phénomènes
migratoires qui permet expliquer quand
même que si la France veut garder une
influence dans ses dans ces dans les
pays qui ont été parmi ces colonies et
c'est pas mal de vouloir garder des
liens avec le Mali, le Burkinafaso,
l'Algérie, mais il faut qu'il y ait ces
échanges qui se fassent, il faut qu'il y
ait des politiques de visa. Qu'est-ce
qu'on va faire ? on va s'enfermer et
puis en fait on va laisser les Russes
gagner influence au sud de nos
frontières. Donc ça pose des questions
qui sont fascinantes, ça les rem en
perspective, ça les nuances et donc on a
eu envie de mettre de nommer comme
lauréat de ce prix ce livre que j'ai
trouvé extrêmement intéressant. Alors le
deuxième livre c'est un livre alors sur
un autre sujet de
Bruno le mer
c'est un livre de Dos Santos qui
s'appelle la formule de Dieu. Alors moi
j'ai adoré ce livre en fait ce livre
c'est un livre qui est très enfin qui
maintenant a quelques années mais en
fait tout part de de c'est une histoire
vraie heinstein en 1929 reçoit un un un
télégramme d'un rabin new yorkais
Goldstein qui lui dit "Croyez-vous en
nous ou non en Dieu ?" réponse espérée
en une courte réponse
télégram et Einstein répond "Je crois au
dieu je crois en le dieu de Spinoza" et
en fait tout le livre consiste en fait à
aniser qui quel est le dieu de Spinoza
et quel est le dieu d'Instein. Parce
qu'en fait Einstein était très spirituel
et a beaucoup s'est beaucoup exprimé en
fait sur sa conception de Dieu disant
"Je ne crois pas que Dieu soit un soit
un soit un un comme quelqu'un qui
régante ma vie au quotidien. En fait, je
vois Dieu dit-il dans euh la beauté et
l'harmonie des lois de l'univers. Et
tout le livre en fait explique de façon
très scientifique où on est la science
aujourd'hui, ce qu'elle peut prouver du
dieu d'Instein et c'est passionnant.
Tu connais Nietzsche un peu ?
H
euh 3è bouquin,
j'en ai dit deux. J'en ai certainement
un troisième qui me viendra à l'esprit.
le
non, permettez-moi juste, mais je voilà,
je je je vous ai parlé de certains
sujets qui sont ceux de l'enfer
numérique. Ça peut être le trè mais ça
va me revenir d'ici là.
Comment il s'appelle ton dernier bouquin
?
L'enferenfer
numérique voyage au bout d'un like et je
vous ai fait le voyage d'un like avec
tous les enjeux.
Combien ça coûte ? Quelles éditions ?
Édition Lilien qui libère. Il est en
poche 9,90 €.
Euh un conseil pour les jeunes
générations, une bouteille à la mer,
quelque chose d'impérissable. En fait,
ce que je voudrais dire à tout, enfin
pour moi, il y a un message qui est
important et qui est un peu la la sève
de ce que nous avez nous avons dit et
qui est un message, c'est que nous
entrons dans un monde bas carbone mais
haute matière.
On va faire demain nos bilans en matière
comme on fait aujourd'hui nos bilans en
carbone. Les entreprises, les États,
vous et moi comprendrons que nous ne
pouvons pas vivre dans un monde qui soit
bas carbone et qui ne soit pas basse
matière et que tous les sujets
aujourd'hui qui sont extrêmement
importants autour de la baisse de nos
émissions de matière de de carbone
pardon vont être basculés
progressivement vers la question des
ressources naturelles et les jeunes
rentrent dans ce monde là et ils sont
les acteurs de ce mondeel parce qu'ils
ont tous dans les mains un téléphone
portable. Un jeune français aujourd'hui
qui a entre 18 et 25 ans en est à son 5e
téléphone portable. Il passe des heures
sur TikTok. Il est le faire de lance
d'un monde haute matière. Et je vous
pose la question vous les jeunes, est-ce
que vous êtes si écolo que vous ne
pensez ? Est-ce que vous êtes si Greta
Tonbert que vous ne le croyez ? Vous me
dites à moi qui suis la génération en
avant,
quel âge tu as ?
43 ans. Vous avez pollué avec le
plastique, vous polluez avec les
émissions de CO2 et il faut consommer
moins de viande. Mais je suis
complètement d'accord. Mais vous êtes en
train de remplacer ces types de
pollution par d'autres pollutions,
matières qui sont les pollutions du
numérique et vous êtes placé face à vos
premières contradictions. Dans les
années 68, en 68, on sait ce qu'on fait
nos parents. Ils sont sortis jeter un
pavé et après ils sont devenus cadre
supés du CAC 40. C'était le paradoxe de
la génération 68. Il y a qui surgit un
paradoxe de la génération Greta. Vous
êtes écolo jusqu'au moment où vous avez
un portable entre les mains. Et donc mon
message, c'est où est votre cohérence
sur ces sujets-là ? Dernier message en
s'étant un tout petit peu troublé. Euh
le pouvoir de notre imagination et notre
capacité à réinventer nos sociétés va
au-delà de du pouvoir des technologies à
à changer notre monde. Ayons confiance
en ce pouvoir de créativité qui est le
nôtre.
Tu connais le poème le renoncement de
Saint-Pierre ? Non.
Et moi, je sortirai de ce monde où
l'action n'est pas la sœur du rêve.
Guillaume Pitron, merci.
Merci à vous.
[Musique]